this is a production of Cornell
University
so Mike Scanlon say hi Mike and I are
really really happy to be here today for
the undergraduate symposium for the
Plant Sciences majors and Friends where
we had a fantastic class this year our
plant science 4950 course all of these
students were involved in the class they
worked really hard putting their
presentations together and we're happy
to have everyone here today to see the
results of not only the hard work during
class to put this presentation together
but the results of the research and
extension experiences that our students
have had that both Mike and I find to be
amazing and inspiring
firing the first thought today is
actually not from one of our
undergraduates but from the recipient of
the celibate fellowship yes
selling fellowship sorry
grant Thompson and that fellowship grant
will talk about a little bit but it's
about undergraduate mentoring and grant
is a graduate student in Jenny Cohn
difference allowed and he will be
actually starting an assistant professor
position at Iowa State University fairly
soon about which he is not in any way
nervous grants undergraduate student
that he worked with is Michelle Chen and
the two of them to get today will give
us a brief overview of the work that
they did and then we'll begin the
students that were involved in our class
so grant and Michelle please come on up
and the clicker should work the title is
reflections on mentoring a learning
laboratory for grads and undergrads
thank you very much for the introduction
so I'm grant Thompson and as was
mentioned the title for this is
reflecting on mentoring learning
laboratory for grads and undergrads and
so I'll give a little bit of background
over all talk a little about the solu
fellowship and mentoring it's it's
really more than just the research that
we've done together give some of my
perspectives and Michelle will give hers
on it and kind of the important
experiences we've walked away from this
the research which you actually won't be
hearing a whole lot about is part of the
Baltimore ecosystem study so this is an
experiment or it's part of a longer
running experiment looking at land use
change in urban grasslands and how that
is affecting soil micro biomes and kind
of the various controls on that that we
see and this work that we've done
together has been supported by a
generous donation of the cella family
for the excellence in mentoring
fellowship so it was endowed by mark and
Lisa sellou of prides corner farms
it's $50,000 annually to one recipient a
graduate student in each of the five
sections of sips and it's for students
who have demonstrated previous and
ongoing commitment to mentoring of
undergraduate researchers it's been
really critical for me this past year
for the support that I've had both in
finishing my dissertation in working
with Michelle and it's just been a
fantastic experience and so as I've
mentioned it's more than just the
research of course there's all of the
training that goes along into it
showing Michelle how to do PCR take lab
knows amplified DNA quantify what we've
had but it's also a process of building
relationships and inspiring the next
generation students who are going out
into research careers into academia into
wherever life takes them after Cornell
and what this has been able to do is
have allow any kind of a more focused
and intentional approach to what I've
been doing in the lab for years working
with undergraduate students and so we've
had a series of regular weekly meetings
checking in and seeing about progress
talking about pitfalls troubleshooting
hurdles etc as a graduate student most
of the time I'm focused on the research
end of things communicating my science
to my peers to my advisers at
conferences talking to extension
audiences so really working with an
undergraduate researcher has forced me
to kind of slow down reflect and think
about my own science about how I
approach things that may be now it's
kind of not automatic but certainly
ingrained in me that I don't kind of
think about those things as much anymore
it's also given me a lot of really
valuable lessons in terms of what is
appropriate goal-setting how do you
motivate a student experiencing
challenges in the lab how do they move
forward with their own time management
so it's really a lot about leadership
and people skills and you know frankly
admitting when things aren't always
doing well you know if we're having
trouble in the lab okay what's what's
not working what can I do to change that
and so I think that's a really important
thing that I've walked away from this
experience with and it's really company
form and
kind of solidified my teaching mentoring
philosophies which I've had to
articulate quite a few times over the
past years I've applied for different
professors positions in various
institutions and I've had a lot of
really fantastic mentors in my career so
it's really been an opportunity for me
to pay it forward and give back working
very closely with Michelle as well as
undergrads that I haven't asked I'm here
to talk about my experience with us um
so primary or this is my second year
inductee organism slips so primary uh
prior to this I worked with all of the
students um we have bunch of different
uh post PhD students um so what I really
got to enjoy from this mentorship was
the ability to go beyond just working
with like bouncing off different
students really focusing and working
primarily with Grant on comes fresh
shots at the black square lawn study and
so last semester I worked for his
research and this lasted I got some sort
of had my own projects with us so I
really got to be in charge and
experience all the challenges and and
joys of doing that um it was an
opportunity for me to really see the
bigger part in research like I don't
have as much of a background in plant
science so asking a questions how does
my work fit directly into his project
and into the figure box where lawn study
seeing all of that sort of piece
together and like tell the bigger story
was really interesting journey uh and
also uh part of the mentorship was just
asking him about like about research
about graduate student least you know
like t graduating with spring so I
really got to see all of the work that
he plays with his dissertation his final
um I know like exams and his exit
ceremony so really getting to see
potentially if I really want to go into
research how might my like be and also
just like developing like a relationship
with a mentor
research that I might career in life
advice so I got to UM when I was
applying for internships earlier this
winter I talked to him about how to
raise certain applications how to really
articulate my interest in my um my
creative layers and that actually works
out really well and so just to wrap it
up I think you know we all maybe take
for granted or just kind of intuitively
understand the value of mentoring and
the support that it takes to be able to
provide good mentorship and I think it's
a fantastic opportunity for
undergraduates and graduates I think we
both have learned a ton from each other
and just kind of going through the
process of working together you know I
think one of the important things when
it comes to mentorship is not only the
informal process but having people to
check in with having kind of maybe a
formalized way to get feedback about how
mentoring can be improved and I've had
I've checked in with a number of people
and just kind of done so informally but
I think any way that we can formalize
that moving forward would be good and I
just really wanted to say thank you very
much to the sella family for their
support it's been fantastic this year
and Michelle will be going to records
this summer for a research experience
and as was already stated I'll be
joining Iowa State so certainly this
experience has been really formative and
helping people think so - thank you
[Applause]
the title of Rico sock is plant and
pathogen wars outside the cell the X DNA
X DNA's system so hi everyone
Andrey : and I'm a plant pathology
implant microbiology concentration today
I'm going to present some of them work
at Professor Acadian today's lab
studying pongo genetics and genomics the
topic of my today's talk is hunt and
pathogen worse outside the cell
the actress all our DNA actors already
ate systems so when we talk about DNA we
usually think of it as a molecule that
carries genetic information and usually
resides in the nucleus or other work
announced but this idea of intracellular
DNA it's radically overturned with the
discovery of the new fulfil actress our
trap so you fulfill is a type of human
immune cell that normally looks like
this and when they encounter a microbial
pathogens they can't flatter themselves
and secrete in a outside the cell to
form this web-like material to trap a
microbial pathogen to immobilize them
and prevent them from further infection
and this mechanism is also actually
discovered in plants so it was
discovered that actress alert the MD&A
can be secreted by plant root tips and
what's shown here is that um julienne
rods and also pointed by the black arrow
is the pea root and showing in green is
a fungal hyphae of a fungal a plant
fungal pathogen and pointed by the white
arrows is a slime layer that's composed
of DNA and other proteins and this one
layer is separating the green of the
fungal hyphae from approaching the plant
root tips to continue infection and when
we treats this system was purely an h1
on this will happen so the fungal this
slime layer will be loosened and the
fungal hyphae can now penetrate through
the DNA complex
reach the planter tip to cause a hundred
percent root rot
so as a happens a lot between our host
and passenger interactions when a plant
or or many hosts come up with the
defense mechanism the pathogens always
comes up with the color defense in this
case is the actress already being aided
by microbial pathogens so it was
discovered that mammalian bacterial
pathogens can secretly in AIDS outside
the cell to chew up these neutrophils
secreted DNA and release themselves and
then they can continue the infection and
the similar mechanism is also discovered
in plant bacterial pathogens that they
can secrete in AIDS outside the cells to
chew up on the plant secrets
access our DNA however there hasn't been
any report on whether we're not fungal
pathogen can seek reach actors are again
aids as a counter defense against when
secreted actors are DNA so our lab is
asking the question whether this counter
defense mechanism is also present in the
plant fungal system and the model fungus
that were using is Kokomo's Heather
office which is an epic traffic one
pathogen that causes sodium currently
flood and to study the actors our DNA
system in cochlea Heather Chavez we use
bioinformatics force to generate 30
candidate genes that are encoding being
aids in the fungal genome and then if
it's secure if this encoding actors are
being AIDS whether it is secreted when
all will be important so we analyze them
for secretion and picked on the ones was
the predicted secretion signals and so
far we've analyzed our eight of them and
they are all marked in pink here and
among the eight had a moderate candidate
one was identified as important for
virulence and also of it had secreted
near AIDS activity which is marked in
green here and the protein IV of this
gene is one who for 206 and in my
project I am screaming another candidate
gene and the protein ID is one
to see if also encodes the actors are
being Hg
so study this gene I generated mutants
with this tree and billiards in my
fungus and firstly I performed a
Baroness sa inoculated corns with four
different strains the first one is well
paid and also the second one as a
positive control which is a mutant was
the identified on security agent deleted
Delta one point four to six and the rest
- Azam the other two are my mutants that
are lacking my gene of interest 197 62
and I collected my collected Leafs of my
infected corns and measured the legal
ends of every legions on the third leaf
out of my courts and used average legal
ins as a criterium for virulence so as
you can see that this is a symptom of
course impacted by wall type and this is
a zoom picture of what the Legion and
this is the symptoms caused by the
positive control and as you can see and
based on statistical tasks the virulence
of the mutants is significantly
decreased compared to wall type however
the difference of ruins between the well
Kuip and shoe of my mutants wasn't
significant which any case that is 197
62 is likely not a variance factor or
worse your interesting why whether this
one 97 6 or 2 is encoding an actress or
gain 8 so I also performed a teenage
activity test I cultivated the
straightest and khalakka media from the
cultures and maize for suspension and
puts equal amounts of sports aspiration
into individual a keyboard cubes and
added six surface sterilized core leaf
pieces of into worthless cube and
incubated both of the tubes at room
temperature with scheduled shaking for
three days after three day I centrifuge
both of these cultures and use a few
traits to treat lung that DNA to see if
there's a difference between lung that
neotec Astra so if the King is encoding
for a DNA actress our teen AIDS this is
the result that we're expecting so all
the twelves campaign
that being a here and this is what long
that a origin looks like without any
treatment and when it's treated when
steer is one they will there's um
there's nothing left
oh when is treated with me an h1 and
when they are treated with so welcome
children's as you can see that the love
the DN a is no longer impact or less
intact and indicating that the lambda
DNA is digested and these two lines are
created with few traits of well type
culture cultivated with corn leaves and
these two are treated with cultures of
well type cultures without corn leaves
which in as you can see that there's an
increased amount of DNA activity in
these two lanes which indicates that
there's an association between the
presence of core leaves and also the
DNA's activity and when we treat lambda
P na with the positive control which are
mutants lacking one for 206 oh we can
see that compared to wall type there's a
decreased amount of flubbed a DNA
digestion indicating that this gene is
encoding for an extrasolar being aids
because lacking this gene will make a
decrease the amount of the in a stash
via a digestion so I apply the same as a
to my Newtons and this is a result I've
got so this is longer than a by itself
and when it's treated when spean is
purely and h1 and this is wall type and
these last four lanes are my mute are
treated with my mutants and as you can
see there's no obvious decrease of AIDS
activity but however you might also
notice that in the positive control here
that there's also another obvious
decrease in a kinase activity which I
have to be honest that these tests are
quite crude and there's variation
between each trial indicating that
there's many feel of there's many
unknown factors in our experimental
design which are we are Co trying to
improve but this is definitely not an
easy task because there's little
literature associated with filamentous
fungi holding in a
not to mention about functional analysis
our definition tire and also this is now
the end of story because I also
performed a phylogenetic analysis of DNA
encoding genes we identified using
bioinformatics tool we identified the
Versa locks of the identified on
secreted in asian cochlea almost 1.4 206
and found is worse about seeing other
plant Hangul pathogens that has cochlear
buzz victory which is a old pathogen and
we're asking the question to what the
logs of 104 306 had similar or
functionally in other pathogens we're
asking whether it has a similar
functions in another pathogen that
infects another host and also in facts
another plant part because um see
victory is actually a crown pathogen and
I have generated the mutants of see
victory lacking this ortholog and I am
performing the Baroness essays on
recently so in conclusion according to
our virulence has 1 9 7 6 3 q is likely
not a burdens factor and according to
our DNA ace has one i 762 might not be
as secreted being 8 so we have a lot of
future research going on one is that um
we are as I mentioned before we're
improving the DNA SSA order to get more
consistent result and secondly as I
mentioned there's a association between
the presence of core leaves and the
increase in a stack tivity so what we're
asking whether the presence of core leaf
is inducing on the DNA's activity or
assistant Lee that because of the
presence of core leaf there's better
fungal growth also we have a lot more
candidates to analyze and many of them
are Co are under current research and I
am studying the water log of 104 12 6 in
Coakley opps victory and I am saying the
burdens of my mutants in recent days and
last but not least I also want to
mention that in the meantime of this
project I also adapted CRISPR cosmicism
to Coakley out of las Heras coffers
and I'm improving this so that's in the
future research hopefully we can use it
to study to do more sites the specific
research on functional analysis on the
identified on DNA stream so I want to
thank everyone in the Terkel lab
especially my PI Gillan and also our
postdoc kitchen park who have been
helping me a lot and also who send all
my funding sources the RC ARS program
the Jim Grobe only primary research
award and Frederick Kepler memorial
research endowments and now I would like
to take questions questions for Rico so
one would expect that this phenomenon of
being able to degrade our DNA as DNA is
produced by root cups that would be
something more may be expressed in root
pathogens why did you choose to study a
foliar pathogen so when we studied only
first studied our identified actors RDH
gene which is 1 for 12 6 we actually
performed a root si
um to evaluate surveillance and we also
performed a polar I say by evaluating
the virulence on the plant feeds and
both of them show sick decreased amount
of berlin so we're suspecting it could
also be some Authority acre also be
secreted by um leaf and also cochlea bus
has a surface although it's mostly a
foliar pathogen but sometimes they can
also in fact roots other questions
all right thanks
[Applause]
so next we have J Winans who will be
talking on phenotypic phenotypic
variance and disease severity caused by
Fusarium gramineae Arum sampled from
wheat and wild grasses so this is the
work 20% today is the work I did for my
honors thesis here I'm collected from
Northeastern New York a little bit of
background for our memory room it didn't
ascomycete plant pathogen and wheat
barley and corn when it's infecting
wheat and barley it causes we saw in
head by week that's infected the white
and bleached and the infected car and
the [ __ ] molded area is the infected
liberally rod that consumption of this
fungus can lead to vomiting malnutrition
a lot of health concerns for humans and
livestock both and the reason for that
because the mycotoxins this fungus
produces so it produces a bunch of
different mycotoxins on the right here I
have the the six of them that isn't an
inclusive list these are all incredibly
potent mycotoxins of one part per
million and it's dangerous for people to
consume them they're also pretty
economically important because our
environments one of the most
economically important pathogens for
wheat production and then 2014 it was
estimated that a billion dollars were
lost due to who saw him head blight
based off of grade loss so there was
enough micro toxins that you couldn't
sell it for human consumption and
livestock is only at ten parts per
million so like it's pretty close to it
once that you have infected grain
there's very little you can do to get
rid of it or get rid of the toxins the
synthesis of micro toxins vary between
populations so the Corn Belt is
dominated by the 1581 phenotype or chemo
type sorry so normally a fungus isolate
will produce one mycotoxin and fast
quantities more than other ones or it'll
only put this one at all and that's
called its chemo type II upstate New
York region has much more diversity in
micro toxins that are produced by
isolates such as the nh-2
three aton variety 1581 these are all
kind of more present in this region wild
grasses are colonized by fruit sorry I'm
a symptomatically so you won't ever see
the infected spikelets that I showed the
wheat when you're collecting off native
grasses less like a talking accumulation
of a program in your own weight it's
infecting wild grasses as well but the
aggressiveness devices from different
hosts organs are currently unclear so
all this information in mind my
questions was is there a significant
difference in the phenotype and zeal
aggressiveness when you sample for sorry
I'm off of wild grasses and when you
sample for him off of wheat right so
would you see a difference in chemo type
identified here at BCC information
you're gonna get into the methods now
the collection sites we had were in
northeastern New York
way past our culture most agriculture or
wheat is in on this area here so these
are the four different sites you go to
and this is an enhanced version of the
Willsboro research farm there are each
is a precise marking of a grass I salute
that we grabbed and then from this part
we so in total we hit twenty I slits
from grass eight from eight from soon
from eight from Canary redress and four
from Orchard and then 15 from wheat all
clicking around here and then I ran into
the greenhouse experiments this was a
live host inoculations to test disease
severity of incidence so in the
greenhouse I had two lab standard checks
or I had to run three different
inoculation ship because of spatial
restrictions in the greenhouse and so I
would have knock you liked them and then
every week or the next month I would go
back and I would predict take a incident
since the very degrading just is the
disease there and if it is how bad is it
and then on the fourth week I brought
them all back to the lab brush them and
then did a percentage of damage kernels
get really orange and trebled compared
to be
I also did in lab correlation assay and
of my Celia growth right so what I'm
curtisha is the reproductive structures
of Rosario and these are little black
dots and right here this is a celiac
growth si just seeing after five days
how large of a colony did it produce so
that was kind of the book methods never
uncommon of the results so the chemo
typing we found 15 3 aton mycotoxin if
18 1581 and won the Ballon all which is
a pretty standard split or this area we
collected it from chemo sites had no
significant any the phenotypes observed
whether it be is for production I Celia
growth disease in the greenhouse and
damaged kernels however we did see was
that the origin of the isolate so if you
grabbed it from a grass isolate or from
wheat that had a significant effect on
whether it caused a lot of disease or
less disease in the greenhouse and we
see that we final disease rating I took
and so this graph right here this is
either a tomato and the Tsarevich
kernels and that's the correlation just
go just knowing about the two different
ways I was meandering disease those are
correlated be well and then this
regression line is for the grass eye
slits and this one is for the weeks and
then this is what's interesting was that
while this was significant the the storm
damage kernels was not related it was
not significant but the place you took
me
isolate from was not significant for
predicting damaged kernels which is
weird because Deena this is correlated
and this but that wasn't and I'm like
because my theory is my bad I had would
be this one there was four four data
points my steely-eyed pretty see a grill
so I found a trend so this is not
something to show that there is some
sort of significance that if maybe with
a higher sample size we could see a
significant effect what I think is
interesting
it does show that maybe there's a
difference between whether you're
growing larger or you're producing more
spores like that could show that there's
a you know a difference in life patterns
so the inflation of these results
processes cause less disease host
adaptation negative it's unimportant in
colonizing of huge sweet hosts so for
the research we were I'm going to move
in Madison when that's not when these
summer is over but before that I'll be
working on the differentiation between
and excellence and realign excellence so
on this trap which shown here is that
these bars down here this is the reading
link this one is the 15 then this one
appears however 381 and NX does not
differentiate with this so I'm going to
want to do that and see that larger
sample size to see if very thieves
deformation and might see a growth if
those are different I think really do
have a negative relation to each other
good for me to see exactly how much
mycotoxins are being produced by the
grass ice or the grass I slipped when if
I can wheat and the seedlings we tried
this once but the for suspension was
just it just destroyed completely
destroyed every single seedling that we
tried to inoculate I've been working
with for about two years now
personal mentor of mine Jamie coming to
be a great lab manager dr. Gary Bertram
who is my VI dr. Deniz acting here for
all the help of the statistics for this
thesis and Chad Thomas who helped me
grow a house plants that'll make your
time and questions
great job Jim curious is the what parts
of the world where they grow we'd have
the greatest problem which they're aimin
what contributes to that being right so
this arm is kind of a worldwide problem
or in the United States most of my
productions are screened for and then
are separated and not soul cream
consumption in developing countries in
Africa I know that this arm is a pretty
big problem because it's not screened
for well enough so people are ingesting
infected grains other questions I should
point out when you see the presenters
smile it's because they're looking at my
cry and they're talking about something
that was discussed extensively in class
and so far I have to say both presenters
have done the best job of presentation
today it was today so
all right so next we have Kyra Archer
and the title of Clara's talk if she
didn't change it is role role and
elucidation role elucidation of terpene
synthase TPS - in maze a food defense
can you hear me yeah so hi everyone I am
a plant science major and also
nutritional science major and this is a
project that I did for my honors thesis
and I'm happy to talk with you all about
it today um so as Chris said I'm going
to talk to you about a specific enzyme
at TPS - and the role of this enzyme in
Mays defense specifically against corn
leaf a Fitz and green peach aphids so we
all know that may is very important crop
and unfortunately Mays experience is
such a wide range of or bibury from bone
feeding to chewing and stem boring it
just can't catch a break
but I think what's more interesting than
evaluating all of these different
insects that feed is the way that the
plant naturally defends itself against
all of these insects and there's so many
different ways and today I'm going to
talk with you about one in particular
the use of volatile organic compounds so
VOCs are not only defensive compounds
but they can be used to attract
pollinators like bees but if they are
used in defense they're used indirectly
or directly indirectly is when it
attracts natural enemies of herbivores
like parasitic wasps and directly is
when it deters things like caterpillars
and infants from actually feeding on the
plant and so I mentioned this enzyme to
PSU and you're probably wondering what
does this have to do with VOCs um so T
vs juice and enzyme O's found by a
previous postdoc in my lab to experience
a significant gene upregulation in
response to a feed feeding and whenever
we see this in an rna-seq analysis we
think okay maybe it's playing a role in
defense
further elucidation of this enzyme is
found that the primary products are a
little they're a little journal in alone
which are all VOCs so I became really
interested in this because the natural
next question is let's see if these
compounds are playing a direct role in
defense and if you can touch test each
one of them
maybe there's a specific one in
particular that a peds are being
attracted to or deter and this is just a
GC analysis that was conducted by the
post office on GPS tube and this is
showing that the wild-type line that we
have which is a DES knockout line um
does not have the same volatile Peaks
for literal d MN t TM TT and their
little as the wild-type w22
which is amazing bread line that was
used to make this not go and so I had a
variety of different methods for trying
to answer this question what is TPS -
doing a defense and could went a little
narrow little and Jeremy Lin will all be
involved in this event the first was a
choice assay and this assay was meant to
see if a phase or exhibiting a general
preference towards the TPS - knockout
line or not the second was all full
factory assays which appeals to the
aphid sense of smell and this was meant
to determine if little ol mer little or
Gary Nolan Elul were directly causing
some sort of defense or attraction in
the final which was my favorite was on
electrical penetration grab a C and this
was meant to see if a good feeding
duration pattern and frequency were
altered in response to these volatile
compounds that are present in tickets
and so the choice assay the pretty
self-explanatory I planted w22 plant
next to the knockout line that we have
and I put about 20 agents in the center
of the plant a caged it and timed it for
20 hours
um and then I counted where the aphids
choose to go if it was on that w22 or
the TPS - and the reason I chose 20
hours is because a graph that I have
later that I can show you if you want
show
that the gene expression of TPS to its
highest between 18 and 24 hours so it
makes sense to evaluate the offense
within a and the results for this were
pretty surprising I guess um for the
knockout line we see that Athens weren't
actually got into it compared to the
wild type line w22 and I talked about
volatiles before is potentially acting
as direct or indirect defense mechanisms
but what we're seeing here is the
volatiles that are present in the wild
type line and not in the knockout are
actually encouraging the agents to come
to the wild type so after getting these
results I thought okay maybe I need to
reevaluate my hypothesis and look at
these volatiles little narrow little
journal and law as attractants and not
as defense mechanisms so the next thing
I did was olfactory at they this one was
kind of fun I got to watch 8 bits move
around
the glass tube for three minutes
essentially what I did is I put them in
the center and then I introduced the
volatile here and track their movement a
very crude setup and in the future this
will probably be repeated with a y tube
which controls for pressure and air flow
to prevent any other volatiles from
being in the system and to also control
the amount they're actually being
exposed to and the results for this
we're also quite interesting so we see
general little ole here um they're
little and little all show general
movement towards however I based on this
data that I collected and data that I've
collected previously using our Midas I
would deem general Manila as a potential
attractant because although this isn't
statistically significant I've done many
more replicates of this experiment and
we do see a fifth migrating far more
towards during a little oil then away
the next guy is Nair a little and I
would deem this a very clear attractant
for the aphids the reason being of all
of these guys that I tested
the amount of aphids that made a choice
or didn't just stay put and that you was
the highest form they're a little it is
about 65% and we see a highly
statistically significant movement
towards the volatile rather than away
which makes me think that it's and
little is unconfirmed although this
graph looks very promising that the
aphids clearly seem to want to move
toward the volatile um previous data
that I've done with our Midas did not
find this at all they actually I'd
actually found that the aphids are
moving about as equally toward as a way
um and only 10% of the aphids made a
choice in this situation so I don't deem
that enough to say that this could be an
attractive and the final essay that I
did was the electrical penetration graph
passing and how this works is you have
an aphid attached to a probe here which
is attached to a device that basically
amplifies the different voltage
potentials that happen when an aphid
styler is inserted into the leaf and
this amplification gets stored in a
computer and I get a nice set of
waveforms I can analyze and essentially
what this is doing is creating a massive
circuit so we're tracking the difference
in voltage potential and determining
where in the plant and I just want to
show you what I actually have to do for
this happen um this is a feed here and
it is attached with silver glue to a
gold wire that's probably as thin as a
hair and this wire the touch with silver
glucose copper wire which is then
soldered to a brass insect pin and this
pin then goes into the probe that I
showed before and when the aphid starts
feeding the circuit is complete and you
have data that you can analyze
experiment in action and this machine
can take up to eight eight plants at
once I did about 30 plants for each line
and it takes a long time to analyze the
data so it was a lot of work it's a very
cool machine and I definitely my
favorite part about doing this and
unfortunately even though all this is
really cool the results weren't actually
that significant for me um
I separated the results into four
different types the first being an
assessment of the non probing non
probing behavior of the aphid meaning
when it's not feeding um the second
being a pathway phase behavior which is
basically preparation for feeding or
salivation the third being xylem phase
feeding or just inserting the silent to
the xylem and the fourth which is what
we really care about is the flow and
feeding which is when the aphid is
actually ingesting plone and as you can
see if we're non coping and pathway
phase behavior um these results are not
statistically significant they're pretty
similar to one another in terms of the
TPS to knock out in a wild-type and four
xylem and clone face feeding we also see
very similar results and at first I was
a bit discouraged by this but when I
thought about it a little bit more I
think that this could just be indicating
that the TPS you enzyme is not
necessarily playing a role in a fig
feeding behavior but more of a role in
attracting the aphid to the plant and
once it's there
it'll just feed on its own and do
something so the main takeaways of my
project I want to first reintroduce the
goal so the goal was to determine what
role this TPS 2 enzyme is playing in
Mason may say for defense specifically
if the the byproducts of this enzyme
were serving as attractants or deterring
the Athan or something else was going on
and based on the results that I found
you see that Athens do seem to be
favoring the wild-type line which has
the volatiles present over the knockout
which would indicate some sort of
attractive mechanism going on
and then when we move forward and look
at the actual volatiles we see that
narrow little and general little Oh
could be clear attractant stored the
aphid little ol would have to do more
work to assess that and finally because
the EPG results weren't as conclusive
one could determine that the the role of
T PSU is not to encourage feeding
behavior but to encourage a third
attraction so I have a lot of people I'd
like to thank first and foremost George
gender my PA and my postdoc in at
Richter for helping me throughout this
whole project I've been in this lab for
four years now so it's a long time I'd
also like to thank the ASP B education
and outreach team for giving me the
opportunity to present this preliminary
data for this research last year and
fund this project and the hunter ruins
the third presidential research scholars
for funding my research throughout my
time that was a great talk thank you so
I'm a corn breeder so my question of
course is if you shut this TPS two down
what are the downsides for the plant you
haven't I know that wasn't part of your
research but what other things besides
maybe attracting agents could it be
doing for the corn plant I think the
main issue that could arise is when you
shut down this enzyme other terpenes
could be created from the substrates of
the enzyme and unfortunately the scope
of my project did not research those
terpenes but that was my secondary
hypothesis is that those terpenes could
actually be influencing the attraction
or detection of the aphids so you either
could see maybe a difference in a third
behavior but what you would more likely
see is a different implant behavior
[Applause]
all right I think already next we have
Samantha Hackett and she will be talking
about lead and arsenic uptake by
radishes in contaminated orchard soil
Sam thank you so we're talking about a
minute land okay so how did the soil get
contaminated that's a really great
question
so there are sides are used for orchard
soils and that was a common practice for
these pesticides fees from about like
the 1920s and 1950s
and so this land was passed orchard soil
and it's still prevalent it's still
there it's not going anywhere because
it's rather immobile I'm just a good
thing a bad thing you know doesn't gonna
turn water sources but can't really
harmless with much freedom and with that
like there's other areas that are
impacted not just old orchard soils
there was Letty gasoline that was very
common and it's still prevalent
throughout the world but so like urban
soils are always a concern also and this
is a picture of some land that is
contaminated Carrie tell because it's
just a bunch of soil but continuing so
health effects why do we even care about
these lovely toxic metals so arsenic is
very critical when it deals with the
nervous system and cardiovascular system
will cause those fail and then also with
lead those will that will cause
developmental behavioral problems
especially in children and then also
affect your cognitive cognitive function
and then eventually lead to death okay
so um cellular uptake of arsenic so
arsenic is a physiological of toxic
metal and so it's gonna be taken up
through the plant so arsenic 5 it looks
really similar to phosphate and then
arsenic 5 can turn into arsenic 3 in
anaerobic soils arsenic 5 is also then
going to be tightly bound to these soil
particles so leaving it in mobile soil
so because it looks so similar capacity
it's going to be taken up through the
cell by Fossey
order there and then it's also going to
do that in transitioned to arsenic three
by a reductase and then from here it's
going to either restore it in a vacuole
or it's going to go into the xylem and
just go through multiple other cells
basically repeat this whole process will
run over our hope is that then some
plants will store more arsenic in its
vacuoles versus having it yeah taken up
through plants higher places so some
other ways that it's taking off can vary
from plants plants so like rice is going
to have a si si channel and then it
varies as you go through different
plants so let it's a particular
contaminant and that means that it
basically the physical particles if it's
on those leaves or on that piece of
vegetable that you're trying to eat
that's how you would get led ingest it
and that's a concern because we're
growing radishes radishes are in direct
contact with soil and that's also
concerned like lettuce and much other
vegetables some other concerns that we
have are where is it actually in the
soil profile is it going to be in the
upper layer or lower layer in this case
because we're working with pesticides it
is in the upper layer and then also the
contact exposure so do you have
something over that surface of freshly
tilled soil and such and then also a
plan Anatomy you know are we harvesting
the like corn that's under the husk or
are we harvesting the radish wheat
that's right in contact with the soil
and then soil pH also does vary so with
my particular research I had 12 pots
they're all contaminated soil and the
only difference was that half were
fertilized with composted chicken manure
and the other half were just plain and
then plant it radishes and all of them
so results um I kind of just highlighted
the things that we're either trending or
significant and based on Europe and
Asia's standards for lead arsenic they
have one PPI ppm excuse me for lead and
then also 5 ppm for arsenic and that's
for dry weights a vegetable or produce
that you would be consuming and that's
the considered like safe value we are
over that hippie um and so the first
thing arsenic is what we're kind of
hoping for the fertilizer to compete
with Aussie and that's showing a trend
but not yet snick significant so it's
hoping that if I fertilize it more than
there'd be more competition with that
uptake and then from lead with leaves in
the second harvest between fertilize and
not fertilize that was a significant
another one was with the roots um so
that's in there at contact and that's
good that is showing a difference so
since they're lettuce and particulate
contaminate we wanted to show that
difference between when an arsenic so I
did a correlation and this is people
looking at LED and aluminum and beans
and then this is looking at the roots I
didn't show the arsenic because there
wasn't a correlation but you can see
here with this trend line there is a
correlation with that I'm so just going
forward on that's consistent with other
research the options for remediation um
we chose the compost and fertilizer so
kind of just hidden those two bullets
there but you can fuse item or there's a
lot of different options for research
and experimentation and also looking at
other production of life stages but
we're hoping to do was analyze exceeds
unfortunately I should take a while to
see so that's what we're doing right now
but um so instead of like growing
radishes and hoping to eat the actual
radishes you could just produce the
seeds and some seeds those are all
options and to try to fight going around
that contamination
some acknowledgments that I wanted to
say some running with Brian my professor
and supervising me he's spent a lot of
time also like gathered the soil and
doing a lot stuff so that was Austin to
get first-hand knowledge for him and
then Hana was the push-off in Assam and
she was super helpful to filming Hill
unfortunately for their contaminated
soil and then also the greenhouse staff
for being so nice and helping me with
watering so those are references that
we're from my own pictures and such
thank you happy to take any questions
[Applause]
anyone investigated uptake from things
like lead-based paints because that
occurs around houses and people have
garden there and so forth so is it visit
go into the plants that way yeah so um
with lead specifically based that is a
concern obviously because I'm most
affecting so many urban soils and then
also like suburban soils and such
because those are so like a large fleet
the concern is really when they start
getting really small and broken up and
the concern is then is that going to be
directly on chi or whatever you're
eating or if the child is eating it or
whoever's eating it you know so that can
be amended with like washing regimens or
removing that top layer of soil we're
just removing those chips of paint
there's plenty of research on it because
there was such a scare and so many
people got um basically sick from it
yeah
there's a ton of research on it and like
now they're looking at specifically what
plants and crops are safe to grow with
thank you the questions
hi so I know that you talked about more
of the soil effects on the uptake but I
was curious on if we know anything about
whether or not the plant has control
once it's in the cell on whether or not
you can like store it in vacuole rather
than going back to like the harvested
parts of the plants yeah definitely
so that's gonna vary plant to plant or
species to species really the plants
don't want it in them it's typically
toxic there are some plants that will
just take up an abundant amount and
that's not really those are kind of not
considered excluders you know they are
they're the ones that people usually use
to try to remove the text metals from
the soil but besides that so it's very
common for the plants to stop it at the
flowering and seeding or flowering and
fruiting phase because that's their
offspring and they don't want any other
toxic things to go into that and it's
common for that uptake to basically halt
at that point and that's where like
growing corn or beans and stuff like
that is better or like seen as more of
the solution and that's why I like
permaculture is a very common thing in
those soil isn't like why it worked is
there still a look and grow on those
lands thank you hello so in your results
there was like a 23 something but it was
plus or minus 17 I wanted to like ask
you how you explain that okay so those
are basically the averages of all my
results and then the plus and minus was
the standard deviation does that answer
your question
why was it so variable this question why
is it so variable um I mean I think I'd
have to look at it specifically but uh
there is a plus or minus 17 I guess
because out of those six I had a number
of radishes like harvest see it wasn't
just like one from each pot but it was
like six or seven from each pot and then
tried to reach that wheat goal and that
was necessary for the test and that was
kind of I guess I need to look at the
specific number I'm sorry but yeah does
that answer your question
Thanks
[Applause]
alright next we have Alison comer
Alison's the title of Alison's talk is
diseases in forage intercropping systems
ready
Alison alright thank you so I'm a
December 2018 graduate so this project
is ongoing and I'm working on the data
collection pretty much starting next
week so my presentation is gonna be a
little bit of different format than
everyone else's so I'm gonna start with
an overview of the problem that my
project is meant to address here in New
York we have a very large dairy industry
an organic dairy production is growing
in order to support dairy cows we use
forages as animal feed so by extension a
lot of forage crops are grown in New
York forage production is becoming
increasingly more important as organic
production spreads because there are
certain requirements organic producers
to use a certain amount of fresh feed
that has to come from forages which it's
easier to grow them locally so forage
production continues to expand but it is
being threatened by extreme weather
events in our area so as you can see
from this graph graph on the right we've
had a 71 percent increase in extreme
weather events or very heavy
precipitation in the Northeast since in
2014 so these weather events have caused
a lot of damage to forage production in
our region and intercropping has been
proposed as a mechanism to buffer for
introduction from these extreme weather
events so intercropping is part of a
bigger scheme called system resilience
so this is increasing the system's
tolerance to extreme weather events and
different environmental conditions so
intercropping falls into the absorptive
capacity so this is increasing tolerance
of the system by using diversifying your
crop and essentially not putting all
your eggs in one basket there's also
other ways to make your system more
resilience one is the adaptive capacity
so opening up your cropping system to
more management strategies such as
introducing tidal drainage or irrigation
to cope with weather events that are
sort of new to the area that you're
starting to see more of in your area and
there's also the restorative capacity so
this involves recovering from a crop
failure with external support so that's
going to be things such as crop
insurance so a closer look at
intercropping intercropping is the
practice of sowing multiple crops in the
same field at the same time so here you
can see a strip in your cropping system
where you have maize soybean and OH
that are all grown in alternating strips
so essentially the idea with this in
terms of system resilience is that if
you have a really tough year for soybean
so you have a lot of one passed or the
weather is not great and you see a
failure of your soybean crop two-thirds
of your field is not soybean and so you
don't have complete failure because you
can rely on your maize and oat crop to
support you so there are several
different types of intercropping the one
I just showed is strip which you can see
here on the right there's more
alternating type such as row strip and
row which you'll see in a push-pull
system the system of intercropping that
this project uses is mixed so all the
seeds are essentially put together at
the beginning and then planted out
randomly so the objective of my study is
to determine the prevalence of pathogens
in these diverse organic forage systems
that also include the use of
intercropping so some of the smaller
questions that I'm looking at is are we
seeing a difference in disease pressure
when we have an annual inter cropping
system versus a perennial perennial
intercropping system are we seeing a
difference in disease pressure when we
have multiple susceptible species
present versus one susceptible species
to a disease and are we seeing my
difference in disease pressure when we
have a plot with one cultivar or a pot
with both of ours that have varying
resistance so some might have high
resistance in the pathogen and others
might be very susceptible so this year
we have about 12 crops that are involved
in this different intercropping
systems so for the perennial our main
crop is alfalfa which is involved in all
four different treatments and for the
annuals it is triticale so there are
four different diverse
Gidi treatments the low diversity
consists of one species one cultivar the
conspecific treatment is for Dakar
cultivars of one species the hetero
specific treatment is for different
species one cultivar each and the high
diversity treatment is for different
cultivars of four different species so
this is part of a larger experiment
called the fire trials which stands for
forage intercrop resiliency experiment
so this is a large experiment where they
use four different diversity levels of
both annuals and perennials are being
grown by a Matt Ryan's lab group and
they're looking at how resilient really
is the system so measuring things such
as forage quality and biomass and yield
and this is an example of what one block
looks like so there's perennials here
and annuals and you can see there's the
four different levels of diversity in
each and there are five blocks those
like this each one of the pots is about
30 by 50 feet
this trial is also big replicated at the
University of New Hampshire and the
University of Vermont but their pots are
a lot smaller so here's an example of
what one of the blocks looked like for
the winter annuals about a year ago so
you can see across the four treatments
there's sort of a variation in the shade
of green which is indicative of the
different mixtures of crops that are
present in each treatment so so far for
my methods
last fall I went out to the fields and
collected foliar samples with the intent
to identify some failure diseases and
then compare and check for overwintering
this spring so this involves collecting
foliar tissue samples and bringing them
back to the lab surface sterilizing the
tissue planning it on PDA and sub
culturing the colonies onto fresh plates
for identification on the right this is
probably threaded from on clover this is
commonly known as City blotch so you can
see I make sort of that dot pattern on
the clover itself and then it has kind
of a wild pic snowman look under the
microscope so these are all of the
foliar diseases that I was able to
identify in the fall I just want to draw
your attention to circus row which is a
leaf spot
found on both alfalfa and clover in the
perennial system so we are already
starting to see some cross of diseases
onto multiple species which is something
that I'm particularly looking for so
starting next week and then again once
in the summer and next fall I'll be
taking both incidents and severity
measurements in each of these pots so
I'm gonna for the incidence measurements
I will be placing five quadrats in each
plot and looking at the percent of the
plants out of all the plants in the
quadrat that are infected with some sort
of foliar disease and I will then repeat
this in September and some folks from at
Brian's that are nice enough to do a
smaller measurement of this in July I am
gone and then the severity measurements
will involve the same laying down five
quadrats or plot and using up control
graphs such as the one shown here for
alfalfa to estimate the percentage of
disease in each quadrat so I would just
like to think everyone I worked with in
the Bergstrom lab especially my PI Gary
Bergstrom and the lab manager Jamie
Cummings and the Matt Ryan lab for
growing these plants and fertilizing
them and doing all the other wonderful
things to help them grow my mentor is my
culture who's a graduate student in
plant pathology and my contact in a Matt
Ryan lab is and Bybee Henley who's a
graduate student in silent sciences I
also want to thank the hatch supplement
for supporting my research and I will
take any questions
[Applause]
thanks for that presentation so I'm a
fan of Matt Ryan's work and so um I like
the idea of intercropping but we want to
make it as easy as possible for farmers
and yeah and so it's not very easy to to
do with three or more different
commodity markets if you want to be able
to to sell your season's harvests of
corn and soybean and oats it might be a
lot of work but I like the idea of
intercropping so there's quite a lot of
phenotypic diversity within a single
crop species so is there a way for this
format Ryan and others doing his work to
focus more on you know a single type of
commodity market where you have you're
dealing with cultivars that span
different genotypic diversity and that's
and that's targeted to whatever pest
pressures there are or if it's resistant
if you're trying to tolerate some kind
of change in climatic conditions but
just really have it so that it's it's
diversifying your your farm but also you
want to make it easy on the farmers and
just if they want to deal with a single
commodity market then let them but the
ideas are absolutely applicable but it's
just simply instead of multiple crops of
species multiple species of crops
it's just multiple genotypes of within a
comp yeah so I think there's a couple of
things that the Matt Ryan lab has done
to make this conducive to farmers I
think first of all the mixed
intercropping system where everything
can be planted together you don't have
to do three separate planting regimens
makes it a little bit easier we also do
have the con specific treatment which is
just different genotypes of one plant
which I think helps a lot one thing that
I think is a particularly a struggle
with this is the optimal harvest time
for each of these forage crops is a
little bit different so it's hard to
decide when to harvest the high
diversity forage crop because you might
not get the optimal forage quality of
some of the different crops you have in
there but I do think that versus like a
corn and soybean intercrop the forages
are easier to sell in bulk because
they're just going directly toward
livestock feed so other questions
you
our next speaker is will Dahl who also
change the title the title of his talk
is crisper cast 9 in Lemna minor hi
everyone
I'm will and today I'll be talking to
you about my efforts to implement
crisper gas 9 in the duck weed species
limited minor so why am I talking about
duck weed well it's a small aquatic
plant which grows on the surface of
fresh water and it has some of the it's
one of the smallest flowering plants in
the world I'm dealing with Lemna which
is right in the middle here but there
are five genera with 37 species and each
of them is smaller than a quarter so it
was recently demoted from its own family
lamiaceae a to alumni da the subfamily
of her Asya that's a recent development
and so I'm right in the middle here with
lambda minor so duck weed is a good
candidate for both bioremediation and
biofuels because it has a high tolerance
to high nitrogen concentrations and
phosphorus concentrations which are
characteristic of agricultural runoff
and wastewater so we can use it in
runoff zones to absorb a lot of nitrogen
and phosphorus it also has a very high
growth rate this disputed time of 16
hours is actually a little bit low it's
as a doubling time of about a day and a
half four and a half days so currently
the US produces about half of the
world's biofuels primarily with corn and
soybean but if we can add another system
that could also be doubly used as a
candidate for bioremediation
the effect so as you can see it's it's
somewhat of an invasive species this is
the picture from Prospect Park where
it's totally overtaken this area but
it's indicative of how quickly it can
actually grow so it has a very fast
doubling time and it has a very high
lipid content relative to the lignin and
other contaminants that might make it
difficult to actually remove try a
solicitor and use it
biofuels so in preliminary assemblies
found a lot of worth logs for genes that
have been used in other systems to
promote trials of glycerol hyper
accumulation
but duckweed has some challenges
associated with it we don't have a
complete picture of all the genomes
Lebanon Minor is the farthest along so
we've identified the most genes in it
and a lot of other strategies using a
rabbit OPS's for instance aren't going
to work very well in duckweed because it
propagates clonally primarily we can't
really use the floral dip staple
expression strategy and here's a lemon
that give a flower which is among the
largest species in the genus that I'm
working in and you can see it's pistils
and it's anthers and it's only about a
millimeter to two millimeters long and
it is only produced and they're very
stressed out conditions so we have to
find a way to achieve stable expression
so the first thing that we tried was to
transform the dirt the meristem via
direct injection and we tried to develop
that with an artificial micro RNA
construct regimen that didn't work very
well the expression was biased towards
the vasculature and we were unable to
achieve stable expression throughout
many generations so we're exploiting the
callus State which is a strategy used by
the duckweed to D differentiate and
accumulate a lot of carbohydrates in
order to avoid abiotic stressors such as
frost so D differentiates into a clump
of tissue that then sinks to the bottom
of ponds where it can avoid being frozen
to death
so we induced the state using hormones
and then transform the callus using
vacuum infiltration that protocol is
also used with the artificial micro RNA
constructs and we've tried many
different promoters some of them we
tried P 35 s ubiquitin from maize and
then some native Rubisco promoters and
we've run into some issues with them so
we're trying different combinations of
promoters as well so I am trying to
promote to small guys at a time gas 9
and some associated tags such as em
cherry which is prepended to the cast
nine and a nuclear localization motif
which has also added the cast on so it
can be expressed in the nucleus and
actually cut the DNA so these are three
gene targets for my small guides which I
made it the farthest with the person is
Fido in desaturates which is ortholog
from solanum and bio induced gene
silencing in jatropha which is another
plant that's been used for biofuels
applications it's a succulent with high
triacylglycerol content has been shown
to accumulate tag and also result in a
bleach leaves phenotype there's a sugar
defendant one which is actually sdp one
not SPG one which could be confusing so
that's sealing classes development my
bad it's actually a lipase which causes
the breakdown of triacylglycerol and
when we can knock that out we can
maintain try acid Lister all
concentrations which are desirable from
other transformations such as wrinkled
one and diacylglycerol acid transferase
and then finally we have TG b1 which is
try galactose 'l diacylglycerol which is
a transporter and it can also accumulate
try a slow glycerol and Arabidopsis so
these are the three gene targets that I
made the farthest with small guides up
here so I've had some issues of actually
detecting caste 9 once I've transformed
it it's typically in low abundance and
because of my nuclear localization
signal it was been it's been hard to
actually detect from vegetative tissue
so I extracted nuclei try to detect it
directly and then I've also tried to
optimize caste 9 because I used SP gas 9
which is optimized around 37 degrees
Celsius and so I actually grew the
duckweed at 37 degrees Celsius to make
the this particular enzyme happier
because the duckweed doesn't really care
about that I've been using to guide
targets in some
situations and one in others what we
would expect to see if one guide works
is a an indelible reducing motif but if
to work we would expect to see a
complete deletion via non-homologous end
joining so to detect cast 9 I've
targeted M cherry with antibodies and
also try to detect my small guys with
rt-pcr and that has so far been a little
bit difficult so the goal would be to
achieve stable expression of high lipid
content which would result in low
carbohydrate content because of the load
of producing more proportionately more
lipids we would like to see the growth
viability stay in shape which would be
nice if it could survive accumulating
all these lipids and I'd like to
directly detect cast on the small guide
and the higher lipid content so it would
result in a bleach leaves phenotype like
so at this point I'm not complete with
the project but we could have
successfully transformed cast 9 already
and had a failure to delete on the
pesticide we could also have run into
some issues with the promoters that
we're currently using so that's possible
and on the other end of possibility I
could to go back and detect gas 9 and
then also detect my small guides and the
deletion which would be the absolute
best case scenario but I have yet to do
that so this would be ideal is if my
small guide there thereby cats 9 is
there and I actually delete the gene
that I wanted please so currently I have
seen of leech leaves phenotype unique to
37 degrees Celsius transformants so
hopefully that means that the deletion
is working and I've also detected small
guide via RT PCR but it's I need to redo
it because I'm reaching the end stages
of actually detecting all these things
and I have not yet conclusively detected
all of them the Cassadine is still
difficult to detect I did my first
Western blot
on Jerry and so my antibodies might be
off there might be a lot of issues with
it but we'll see and then my rt-pcr
so with that that's where I'm up to you
right now and I'd like to thank my
mentor Jas
my other mentor Evan and the duckweed
team Joe Almudena
and uma and Alex who did a lot of work
on the artificial micro rna's and then
my my p.i rob partington and I'll take
any questions question I know it's a
preliminary result but what about what
frequency did you see the bleached
phenotype in you're pretty high but only
for Fito in desaturates
so I'd say about 80% for Fito in
saturates but no other transformers yet
question so maybe I missed this in the
beginning part of your talk where you
outline experimental to design but is
the gold then to knock these genes out
or are you trying to adjust the
expression of these using guide RNAs to
the promoters we're trying to knock them
out for these three genes and then we
have different strategies for other
genes so we've promoted wrinkled and you
got to try and promote triacylglycerol
accumulation but these genes are also
associated there's a already established
three gene strategy for tryouts the
glycerol hyper accumulation in other
systems so we've been kind of following
that and these are just the genes that I
happen to make it farthest with and they
all happen to be knockouts the questions
for will
I I love asking molecular biologists an
ecology question so I'm fascinated by
Levi's Lemna the duck weeds and other
floating aquatic plants so is this like
a serious bioenergy crop and what other
types of species like a Zola or some
others are they now targeting for
biofuel crops we think it's serious we
hope it's serious we've been at it for
about five years now algea seems to be
almost a better option at this point but
uh right now we're really hoping that we
can do a good job because it's an
accumulate biomass so quickly and it's
also very resistant it's the highest
growth rate among the higher plants so
hopefully it can do the same thing with
stand the same conditions that we've
seen in vitro and actually accumulate
the fats that we needed to accumulate
hopefully the questions Rob is pretty
serious all right thank you
you
our next speaker is Jeffrey yen and the
title of his talk is comparative legal
development in PO AC my name is Jeffrey
and I'm a student working in Mike
Scanlon slab studying comparative legal
development and similar to Allison I'm
also on a December 2018 graduate so
might not have as much the first thing
I'd like to talk about is what is a lick
you and why we basically care about it
if we look at a grass leaf it is
composed of sheath that wraps around the
stem and also a corresponding blade
portion that extends away from the stem
so if we look at the region in which the
two intersect we can define a region
called the blade sheath boundary at this
blade she's boundary we have a structure
called an Oracle here that is a wedge
that allows the blade to extend outwards
to maximize light capture and also we
have the ligament region which is an
epidermal e derived fringe of tissue on
the top side of the leaf so very
fundamental question in developmental
biology is the formation of boundaries
so here we can see the shoot apical
meristem of a plant and when a new leaf
primordia initiates what has to happen
is that we have to create a boundary
here that separates domains inside the
leaf primordia and the shoot apical
meristem very similarly in floral
development we also get formation but
boundaries signified here as these green
strips of tissue so what's interesting
about this project is that the Lydia is
in fact at the location of the blade
sheet boundary and would like to
understand how the formation of legal
development contributes to the
establishment of the blade sheath
boundary so when we're talking about
development the first things we like to
ask about is the enough taja knee and
what I mean by that is the developmental
sequence in which has to occur for this
particular structure to form so here we
have a histological section of a
longitudinal section of a maze Epis II
in which here we can clearly see that we
have the shoot apical meristem and some
leaf primordia there are just initiating
what I like to bring to your attention
is that as we go further and further
away from the shoot apical meristem the
leaves are more mature in developmental
age we can denote its developmental
stage by giving each leaf a plastic
wrong number in which the newly
initiated leaf will be called plastic on
number one the second one here will be
loud classical number two and the number
increases as we get more and more mature
leaf structures here we can see that in
a maize plant around pasarán seven we
don't see any morphological changes
associated with likio formation however
during plastic on 8 we get this little
tiny bump that's going to correspond to
where the Lydia is going to develop so
to give a little bit more insight on to
how this process occurs we can hear how
the depiction of what just cells
looking at it at its surface view what
has to happen first is that you get a
series of cell divisions that create
these very long cells that are fat in
appearance on an SEM image you can see
them right here in which we call this
the pre module band a little bit later
in development the pre leg you'll ban
would start dividing parallel to the
surface of the leaf pushing a layer of
cells outwards to create what's called a
pre little Ridge we can nicely see the
pre Lego Ridge here on this SEM image
and this structure is going to grow into
the mature legal structure later in
plant development so a lot of insights
have been obtained through studying the
genetics in maize and here we have a
gene of interest called legalist one
when you have mutations in Lydia Swan we
get plants that lack both the Arkell
structure and the little compared to a
wild-type maize plant we can also see
that the blade sheath boundary is lot
less distinct compared to wild-type
plants if we have mutations in barley
and maize they create similar phenotypes
suggesting that this gene is very highly
conserved within de Graaff species so
that brings
me too my model organism which is in the
kind of clothes species in which if you
look at its phenotype at least for some
members of the genus is represented by a
lack of legal structures yeah it has a
very nice oracle structure and the blade
sheath boundary is very distinct so my
main question of interest is how can
members in the kind of Chloe family not
have liguras yet have very nice blade
sheath boundary formation compared to
when we have mutations that disrupt the
league you'll the Oracle and associated
blade chief boundary is lost in other
species so to do that I'm going to use
three experimental approaches first I'm
looking to examine the ontological
development of a kind of Chloe and then
I'm going to look at candidate gene
expression of known genes in maize and
other grass species that are responsible
for legal development and lastly I'm
going to utilize a transcript no-mix
approach to identify novel gene elements
that not might not be present in other
grass species so the first thing I
wanted to see is that if I can't
directly observed particular cellular
differences within these different
developmental domains so to do that I
use scanning electron microscopy to look
at the blade sheet boundary region and
here we can clearly see that we have
three distinct domains the blade sheath
an oracle region if you look more
closely at the cellular features we can
see that here we have sheath cells and
blade cells and you can see that the
sheath cells are characterized by its
bumpiness and if we compare it to oracle
cells we can see that these article
cells are very odd texturized which
corresponds to the secretion of waxy
cuticles on the surface so in order to
find out when this blade sheath boundary
kersek in kind of Chloe the first thing
I did was to do histological sectioning
to find out if I can find these specific
cellular characteristics associated with
sheath
bleh tissue here we can see that this is
also a longitudinal section and we
identify the shoot apical meristem here
and if we count up fast across here we
have passed upon one to posture on three
and oh very plastic on four we can see
this distinct swelling at the base of
the tissue whereas the cells on the top
portions of the leaf primordia all are a
lot thinner and appearance this tells me
that the blade sheath boundaries
probably formed during plastic on four
and gives us more insight on where to
look at during development a very
exciting thing that happened while I was
working on this project is the recent
publication of the kind of clone genome
which gave me the ability to use more
molecular techniques to approach the
problem so the first thing I wanted to
ask is that whether or not known genes
involved in Lydia love formation in same
a species whether or not their
expression patterns are matched with any
kind of closed species so here I have an
in situ hybridization of the gene that I
talked about Lydia Swan and here I just
want to bring your attention to asbestos
the specificity of when and where this
gene expressed so for in situ
hybridization wherever you have this
little colours lighting up that
signifies that the gene X is expressed
at that particular tissue at that
particular stage in development so to do
that what I did is I took known protein
sequences that are in maize and did some
simple bioinformatics in this case I did
a two blast and search to try to
identify
orthologues in a kind of clover that
might correspond to in this case the
Legolas one gene and then a
correspondingly I fished out their
sequences using a genome browser so
afterwards what I can do is I can
construct a gene tree that tells me
whether or not these genes are indeed
true orthologs
so here I have the genes fished out from
the kind of clawed genus and then
compared to citerior maize rice and as
an out-group
I used a parallel
that is present in maze here we can see
that they fostered together in a clade
signifying that I indeed have an
ortholog of Regulus 1 protein and also
we can see here that the genes are
duplicated which isn't surprising
because we know that it kind of Claude
gene oh yeah the genus of many kind of
clone species are actually hexaploid so
the main a pipeline in which I'm going
to figure out whether or not these genes
are expressed is first by using these
candidate genes I'm going to do rt-pcr
to see if they are expressed in the shoe
tips if they are expressed then I can
ask the question on whether or not they
are expressed at the correct time and at
the correct location so by that I'm
going to use in situ hybridization so
here are some preliminary data on what
legalists one looks like any kind of
clone plants so here I have two alleles
of legal asjuan in which I term Legolas
1-1 and Legolas 1-2 we can see that 4-1
we have we can amplify using PCR from
genomic DNA and that tells us that the
gene isn't back there when you reuse
cDNA we can see very faint expression
signifying that the gene is indeed
expressed and it kind of closes shoe
tips we compare that to the Lille number
2 where we get amplification in the
genome yet we do not have any expression
which signifies that that allele is not
being expressed um further on I would
like to do some in situ hybridization on
this specific gene to see if they're
expressed correctly in the right time
and location so that's to be determined
so one other thing that I was really
curious about is that the fact that the
this particular phenotype is only
present in it kind of clawed genus so
signifies that there might be novel
genetic elements that are in the kind of
OG to do that I designed an interesting
system in which I can compare
um what factors are in charge of making
a little so here I want to compare and
you kind of close species that doesn't
have a leg you and compare it to a
relative that does have a leg you will
signified here by these little hairy elk
Grove's
from the top of the leaf so to do that
I'm going to utilize a transcriptomics
approach to look at the differentially
expressed genes in these two plant
species and to see if there are any
specific genes that are correlated with
the appearance of illegal structure did
you do this I'm going to use an
experimental technique called laser
microdissection in which I can enhance
the amount of tissue collected in very
specific locations in this case I will
take tissue that are present in the
blade sheath boundary so by doing that
I'm going to cut out specific regions of
interest using the micro laser
microdissection technique and the two
different species and isolate RNA to do
an RNA seek so in summary my main
question of interest is why we have this
unique phenotype in kind of close
species in which they don't have a leg
you'll you have a very nice lady
boundary to do that I have found out
that the first instances of blade sheath
boundary formation are around plastic on
or and using very simple bioinformatics
I was able to tell that the genes are in
the genome and also expressed in the
shoe embassies however I'm not sure
about its expression in a specific
manner and by utilizing RNA seek
approaches I wish to identify novel gene
elements that are responsible for
creating lingual and finally this
project is funded by the National
Science Foundation and will be later on
funded by the dextral undergraduate
research endowment grant given to me on
special thanks to Mike Scanlon who has
handed down the project to me and to
Josh rainbow who's a postdoc in the lab
that has given me a lot of mentoring and
support also thanks to other members in
the Scanlon lab and
Jerell Davis who has provided C to me
and also gave me a little insight on how
to explore the diversity within the
grass family and also finally to the
Cornell Center of Materials Research on
assisting me on doing SEM experiments
and by that I'd like to open up to
further questions thank you so are you
hypothesizing that the lack of fuel is
related to polyploid nature and
conflicts yeah yeah that's one of the
very interesting hypotheses that I serve
came up very early on because as I was
digging up in literature most species in
the kind of Chloe genus in fact are
hexaploid or even higher boy D bubbles I
think the highest one was 52 um and
that's ubiquitous throughout the genus
so that might be an indication that
maybe there are some because the whole
genome was duplicated and each gene is
represented in three times as much
depandi maybe there's some interesting
we're Navajo gene interaction that is
plays a defect of creating this unique
phenotype another really interesting
observation as I was looking at it is
that the species that do have alig
you'll they tend to be perennial in
nature so maybe that too signifies
something about how this unique
phenotype arises but I don't haven't
found a very good way to test that
hypothesis of polyploid in terms of
creating this phenotype yet but that's
one of the possibilities other questions
for our poster break
you
the second half of our program today
we're mixing things up a bit
Patricia Chan is going first and then
we'll start back with been after patty
so patty we'll be talking today about
the LHB conservatory the green jewel of
campus we are the whole class loved the
title thank you Chris
my name is Patricia Chan it is my
pleasure to present to you today about
my involvement in the Liberty hi Bailey
conservatory or as Chris said the green
jewel of campus I've been working with
the conservatory in the past few years
since my matriculation in 2015 so I'd
like to tell you a little bit about its
backgrounds and about how its progressed
over these years a little bit on the
history of the conservatories on campus
the Liberty High bailey conservatory was
not a first exhibition green house at
Cornell the Sage conservatory circa 1882
to 1923 pictured above over here and it
is round where sage Hall is today
Liberty High bailey himself was a
renowned botanist and horticulturalists
he had great involvement in the founding
of the 4-h organization and was the
first Dean of the College of Agriculture
which is now known as house he founded
the Liberty High bailey heart aureum
which includes Cornell's plant Anatomy
collection or a barium and our
conservatory he believed that
greenhouses were vital to the college's
mission and he had visions of
incorporating living plant collections
into the teaching of botany he is
pictured below the state conservatory
over here the first lhp conservatory was
built in 1931 is a classical Lorden
Burnham style greenhouse however due to
compromised structures it was taken down
in 2010 a much to the thanks in support
of the sips community and cows the
current conservatory was built recently
and open to the public in 2016 and
here's an image of the original lhp
conservatory in the palm house and for
comparison this is our greenhouse today
in the student house now there are a lot
of advantages of being housed in our
modern greenhouse which allows us the
use of state-of-the-art technology
through our plants we have precise light
humidity and heat regulation using our
argot system the top over here
into the Argos boxes which are scattered
throughout the greenhouse which
constantly take measurements of the
light and humidity and then the
automatic system of shades lights events
fans and fog will adjust these in
real-time we have numerous irrigation
options including reverse osmosis water
tempered water and fertilize water to
cater to the needs of our diverse
collection as well as four feet deep of
a custom growing medium in our palm
house for a large trees all of these
factors together allows us to grow pence
for many different climates including
those originating from desert temperate
regions peat bogs or aquatic areas now
why do we have the conservatory for the
first place well it serves our uses as a
living museum for one it's an attraction
for artists and photographers from all
around to come here for inspiration and
it's an oasis for students and faculty
here during ethnic as long and arduous
winters especially this year it's the
home of the titan arum switch I'm sure
you've heard of we stinky and Corolla
switch will talk a little bit about
later and you play a role in preserving
rare and unusual species by sharing
seeds cuttings and Papa culés with other
academic institutions now most
importantly to us the conservatories of
versatile educational tool material from
the conservatory is used to teach
classes and many groups of students and
others come through and tour regularly
the material from the screen house is
used to teach classes such as plant
biodiversity systematics paleo botany
chemical ecology and even classes like
botanical illustration and as a quick
aside to that point here's some examples
of artworks done by myself and my fellow
students and our botanical illustration
classes from subjects that we saw in the
conservatory now during this talk I'll
be cutting a little bit about our recent
projects in continuing to showcase our
biodiversity fortify our collections
database and installing an inground Hans
first off biodiversity as we can't have
a greenhouse without plants inside of it
this picture was taken in 2015 during
the reestablishment of the conservatory
in our new greenhouse so we've got a
Melissa Lynn Bruckner and Chad Thomas
we're a greenhouse workers that
transporting these comically large
cycads in through this much smaller door
our conservatory of both great
biodiversity and we're always trying to
improve on it currently we have about
150 families an inner database we have
over 750 unique specimens accessions
some of the most well represented
families that we have our Castle 8c I
know it is a succulent orchid a sea
orchids cactus II cacti and airy see
Aaron's a little bit more about this
photo in the corner here is this photo
is Amorphophallus long so coolly I which
is the smallest member of the genus
Amorphophallus for reference in the
background here is the patio of its
cousin the largest member of
Amorphophallus Amorphophallus titanum
it's one of the italian arabs that is
just the petiole of one single leaf so
we've got we sing key and Curless which
are two adult blooming sized italian
arabs and people travel from all over
the country in order to Whitney's
witness these plants which over the
course of several days produces
stunningly large inflorescence with a
scent akin to rotting meat over the year
students and faculty have taken seed and
data describing volatile emissions of
these plants in the backgrounds of we
stinky here you may be able to discern
the vegetative state of cruelest and
here's Troilus in bloom who is actually
our first Titan to have blooming outside
in men's gardens you might also be able
to see this fishing line a descending
down into the state as we place a sticky
insect trap in order to check for
pollinators this is a Samantha Schultz
and I read this an audience here so we
have our database which serves to inform
the general public as well as people of
the curatorial and horticultural staff
accessible to the public we have
information like the taxonomy of the
plant including Latin name family common
name geography of where plants are
native to an additional historical and
ethnographic all information we also
have myriad of photos of these plants in
different stages and
supplemental info in the form of videos
or links to additional websites
accessible to the curators and to the
horticultural staff we have information
like the present location of the plants
and flowering times in collecting flower
and times are starting to reveal trends
that can help professors coordinate
their lesson plans with the blooms in
the conservatory over here we have an
example of one of the pages that would
be brought up if you scanned one of the
QR codes in the conservatory to bring
more information about this aerosol
okiya this is alumnus Nick Linus and I
taking down data in order to input in
the database and if you see over here
and here our examples of QR codes puts
it on the place where you can scan them
with your mobile device to bring up
information in the greenhouse now we
have several efforts in order to best
showcase our collections to the public
to disperse information and make
everything more accessible we have for
one organized our plants into
collections series of educational themes
such as convergence or the separate
evolution of similar traits for example
succulents karna pari are criticized and
we have an evolutionary sequence that
goes from bryophytes through Torretta
fights gymnosperms and angiosperms that
goes to the center aisle of the
conservatory as i mentioned before we
have QR codes on about 119 plants in the
conservatory where you can access
information with your phone and craig
kramer runs the conservatory blog which
features plants and current events for
everyone to find online lastly i'll be
talking a little bit about the pond in
the conservatory this is a project that
I was involved in in the summer of 2016
where I worked really closely with kevin
nixon and paul cooper and other
greenhouse staff in order to install
this in order for us to have a venue to
display our aquatic plants a little bit
about this pond it's approximately eight
feet long and three feet deep at its
deepest point it's got like a wooden
shelving in strips infrastructure in
order to display tons of different sizes
it runs fertilized water which is
recycled via the waterfall that's
located in the corner over here and it's
lined with coconut coir which can be
used as a substrate for
aquatic plants the perimeter is kept
usually very moist so it's very suitable
for moisture living plants speaking of
which this pond allows us to grow plants
such as our coniferous plants our
tropical and temperate picture plants
are sarracenia and Nepenthes we have
aquatic ferns like Marcy Liana Zola
bryophytes such as moss and liverworts
and our Victoria water lily pictured
over here it's got this stunning blossom
that goes over the course of two days
with the beetle pollinated strategy over
here is me handling the Victoria water
lily as you can see the pods grow up to
three feet in diameter ongoing projects
in the conservatory include installing a
central trunk in the palm house working
on getting a fake tree using a robinia
bark in order to host epiphytes an
inground succulent and cacti garden and
of course a continued expansion of plant
collections and database information to
increase accessibility I'd like to
acknowledge Kevin Nixon my advisor in
the curator Liberty hi Bailey
conservatory Paul Cooper and the other
greenhouse staff for keeping these
plants alive and raising them so well
Craig Cramer who fastidiously documented
this via his photography and addcom hulu
sedated information on the previous
greenhouses on campus and lastly I'd
like to thank you all for being here
today I knew this presentation piqued
your interest consider visiting the
conservatory which is open on weekdays
from 10 a.m. to 3 p.m. and I'd like to
open the floor to questions questions
from floor to Penny what new species
would you like to see at it if you were
like the curator and you wanted a that's
it what's your dream plants that you
like to have that is a really great
question there's so many that I can't
even begin to think of just a few names
but I would really like to see a lot
more families being represented even
more orders we have some really
interesting fence that I don't think are
advertised very well such as their
umbrellas which play a really
interesting role in the placement of
basal angiosperms and I'd like to see
more plants that are not necessarily
large and showy but play maybe a
historical importance other questions
thanks patty
[Applause]
our next speaker is Ven sword Ben
in addition to being a Plant Sciences
major is the chief Botanical officer at
ecosystems and today he'll be talking
about charged zeolite as a hydroponic
growth medium Ben thank you Chris so as
Chris mentioned I'm a plant science
major concentrating in breeding in
genetics but most of my research and
extracurricular interests is in
hydroponics and so I've been working
closely with Neil Matson on a lot of the
research here and so today I'll be
talking about zeolite as an alternative
hydroponic growth media so the current
problem with hydroponics is that
rockwool is mainly used for starting
seeds and transplanting into along the
growth of plants
the problem with rockwool is that it
starts with its inception and how it's
made so it was originally used as
insulation material and basically what
rockwell is is a rock that's been melted
down and then spun like cotton candy in
order to make this insulation fiber
material and another issue with it is
that it's a non biodegradable and non
reusable so that when the growers are
done with their one round of cycle with
these plants they have to throw out the
rockwool and start with none with new
ones and that just sits in a landfill
and doesn't we'll never biodegrade and
the last issue with rock wool is that it
has a very low cation exchange capacity
making it very inert and cation exchange
capacity is the materials ability to
hold on to fertilizer and other ions
that the plant needs throughout its
growth cycle so the alternative that I
found for rock wool is called zeolite
it's a rock that has a honeycomb-like
structure which allows it to be to have
a high cation exchange capacity
making it able to hold on to those ions
and it's the structure of of it is this
beta cage which creates the actual
structure of the rock and then the alpha
cage which is inside where the ions are
stored and so along with this high CEC
it provides structural support for the
plants it has a water and air holding
capacity that which is similar to
potting mix and it is able to buffer the
pH of the solution because of that CDC
it's the way that I found this media was
through NASA research that NASA did with
a few different types of zeolite and in
their synthetic substrate they used
these three media's here which are
designed it was designed in a specific
way so that the the nutrients in those
three types of zeolite were slowly
released over the course of the growth
cycle of the plant and then able to have
effective yields so this was one of
their trials that they did and with
carrots and this these are over
generations if we're using the media
taking out the old organic matter
sterilizing it and then reusing it and
so as you can see the first round of
carrots was pretty normal but then as
they started continually growing in the
zeolite you can see the carrots started
to form fingers I guess and they kind of
split into different different roots
which is kind of interesting and so the
current uses in industry for zeolite
include hard water treatment in
facilities where they take out all the
salts and other things that are in the
in the water it's used as a soil
additive mainly in in golf courses and
that's the Zeo Pro on the left here
that's the use of that I tried growing
in that but it was mainly micronutrients
there was no nitrogen
anything like that I did a water runoff
analysis and so that didn't really work
but it's also used as an odor eliminator
in horse stalls and cat litter and the
last thing which is pretty skeptical is
a detox which I wouldn't recommend
anybody so the commercial application
which I am trying to use this for is my
startup company called eco systems we're
making kitchen top growth chambers for
the consumer to grow their own culinary
herbs and you can think about it kind of
like a Keurig machine for plants where
you put the pod into the system fill up
with water and then it does everything
else for you it creates a controlled
environment for the plants and Vermont
and the app reminds you when you need to
do anything to take care of them so my
efforts with zeolite are trying to
develop this growth pod and so the first
experiment that I did was a germination
experiment there was five treatments and
three replicates of each treatment just
to see if it would happen just to see if
it could effectively germinate these
cilantro seeds and we so the treatments
the first one the control was with the
tap water soak and then a CEA fertilizer
recipe 1x strength soak going all the
way down to 8x and then a addition of
magnesium on the t3 and the CEA recipe
is basically just a two-part nutrient
solution with 125 parts per million
nitrogen target so the results from this
experiment are that I had high
germination across the board
besides the tap water treatment which is
kind of interesting and so the zeolite
was able to hold on to the nutrients for
the seedling stage but the design of
this experiment was such that there is
no tray or anything that would catch the
runoff water underneath these pots so
after the seedling stage the growth kind
of stopped and I I think this is due to
leaching from
the just a clear water irrigation that
we were giving giving the plants and the
highest fresh weights and root weights
were observed in both t5 which is the
CEA 8 X oak and the CEA rescue plus
magnesium so as you can see the
magnesium one over here and the 8 X
right here and they have very
substantial root zones as compared to
these other three so the next experiment
that I did was trying to create this
sort of pod and the experiment here is
to replicate the different methods that
we might use in our system in our
product to kind of to provide this
service to our customers so the first
except the first treatment here is just
a it's kind of like a control with the
rockwool cubes and I'm growing lettuce
in this experiment
so there's five trays with four plants
in each tray and this replicate or this
treatment was being topped fertilized
with the the greenhouse fertilizer that
just comes out of the tap and so those
nutrients were allowed to kind of
accumulate in the tray and this would
simulate if we were to have the consumer
add in nutrients to the reservoir
instead of having the nutrients in the
pod and then these two treatments were
with charge zeolite so zeolite soaked in
CDA 2 X and Z like charge charged in CEA
4x and so this is what it looked like
when I first started I took lettuce
seedlings and took away the rock wool on
for the majority of the rock wall and
left the roots intact transplanting them
it's the zeolite here and then I just
put the entire rock wall cube in the pot
on these trials and so the results for
this I took yesterday and so
it's awesome this is exactly what I
wanted so the highest yield comes from
the zeolite 4x so at one of the main one
of our main options moving forward
getting closer to product launch and
then this isn't necessarily an
experiment but this is just some
anecdotal growing that I did with the
hydroponics Club and so we did we grew
three carrots in a Dutch bucket system
purple carrots and next to it we have
beets and I know there's no control or
anything here but it's just kind of a
fun little Pro experiment and everybody
remembers this slide from the NASA when
big when they tried growing carrots well
this is what I got which is awesome
that's kind of cool so yeah they had the
same same kind of fingers that the NASA
carrots did and and a similar similar
height and fresh weight so yeah and this
is the prototype right now that we
currently have for our unit and I like
to call them Zeo pods and it's basically
charged zeolite in the base with a
little bit of rock wool on top for the
seedling germination and then enclosed
in the unit and everything so far has
been working pretty good in my house
so that's nice preliminary conclusions
from this or that zeolite has a water
and air holding capacity that's
comparable to potting mix the CEA is
adequate the whole nutrients for at
least the seedling stage zeolite zo pods
the the 4x oak was pretty across the
board and the zeolite is easily sipped
washed and autoclaved and able to be
used again unlike rock wool which is one
of the main reasons why I set out
studying zeolite so that's great and in
root crops it causes them to almost
bifurcate the
route and cause these formation of
fingers on the roots and further
experimentation I'd like to do over this
summer includes soaking the zeolite
incense Agra one of the issues that I
had in those trays was that the pH tends
to shoot up really high over the growth
cycles of these plants and we're not
we're not we want it to be able to have
the consumer not have to do anything to
adjust the pH in any way so I've already
tested this I've already tested this
fertilizer in my food computer that I
built and it's great it does it does its
job it regulates the pH keeps it at five
point eight which is really nice
and so hopefully if I socio light in
that and keep them in the trays it'll do
the same thing and then I'd like to do
more root crop trials and more Zeo pod
trials with different combinations so
and with that I'm just like to thank dr.
Neil Matson for being my advisor in all
my research Johnson not in the JumpStart
program for funding everything the
hydroponics Club for being my pride and
joy KP a greenhouse staff or especially
Julie for everything that she's done in
the greenhouses for me and my team at
ecosystems so thank you very much I'll
take some questions if they're right
[Applause]
are the fingers that grown root crops
are those desirable like what's the
what's the point of them I think they're
pretty cool but in a supermarket I doubt
that they would sell very well because
everyone would be like wow those are GMO
carrots nobody wants to do that yeah but
Chris thought that it might be the fact
that when the root apical meristem
encounters something in its path it
tends to split so yeah I'd like to see
if that happens with like other crops
that every I don't know maybe they just
for some reason didn't see that result
on that first time I don't know why then
that happened but I saw it and all the
other all the other trials dissecting
the root tips did you try that I haven't
tried that yet no but I would expect it
to grow more similar to soil
absolutely thanks man
[Applause]
our next speaker is Kelly Damon and she
will be talking about the hunger games
of cabbage varietal susceptibility to
black rot Kelly all right so thank you
everybody good afternoon I don't know
what I just did okay we're good so as
Chris said my name is Kelly Damon today
I'll be presenting on cabbage varietal
susceptibility to black rot and I did
this research in dr. Christine smarts
lab over the past summer so a little bit
of background about the project of this
goal it was essentially to identify the
different levels of susceptibility to
black rot and commercially available
cabbage varieties that cabbage farmers
would use in their own fields so a
little bit of background about the host
the disease and also the pathogen so the
host that we were running this
experiment with is cabbage
it is a cruciferous vegetable which is
part of the Brass Casey family I do have
pictures in case somebody doesn't know
what a cabbage looks like we have the
cabbage heads up here and just showing
you a little bit of differentiation
between it and then also in the middle
just a little bit of the cabbage growth
itself agitated grow so New York is
actually one of the top producers in the
United States of cabbage they produce
fresh as well as processed cabbage
including sauerkraut and it's estimated
value of production is forty eight point
six million dollars and that's according
to a 2017 sentence report done by the
USDA so a little bit of background about
the disease that I'm talking about today
black rot black out was first identified
in New York in 1896 and essentially
since then has been a common issue for
cabbage growers throughout the state
this disease does cause a lot of
academic growth or excuse me
economic loss to growers as it produces
undesirable heads of cabbage that the
farmers can't bring to the market to
sell and it also decreases the yields
that the farmers see
black rot is transmitted multiple ways
first being through seeds or transplants
that are already infected with this
pathogen as well as crop degrees that
were left over in the field and weeds
surrounding the field but its main
source to infect a crop is through water
droplets so such as rain or other
splashes and forms water so the pathogen
that causes black rot disease is known
as Xanthomonas campestris path of are
compassed risks and I'll be referring to
this as xs-3x ec throughout the
remainder of this presentation and you
can see here on the left side of the
screen the screen that it's a
gram-negative bacterium and this is just
a what I played it out to kind of show
you some of its characteristics and then
over here on the right side of the
screen you could see it's very
characteristic yellow v-shaped lesions
so how does this pathogen essentially
get into the plant to cause this
infection so xcc generally enters
through the high codes of a plant and
the highe thought is essentially just
modified pour along the leaf leaf margin
of the plant and you can see that right
here and from the height of codification
fluid which is essentially just water
build up right here is an easy source to
get contaminated by bacteria so the
bacteria essentially will move in to
this little droplet of water and you can
see how easy it is for it sir
essentially affecting the plant and
getting into the vascular system of the
plant
however the height of thon is not the
only entry point for xec as it can also
come into the plant through different
types of wounding such as bibury so
insect damage also held along with
different mechanical damage so one
secksy see is present in the plant
itself it can actually survive in this
island for many many months until
favorable conditions arise this is
essentially what what causes the large
the issues for the growers because they
don't know if their plants have black
or not until you get conduction
conditions which are warm and also wet
and once those condition of conditions
arise the bacteria can produce multiply
out very rapidly and then go
systemically throughout the plant
essentially getting into the cabbage
head itself and this image here is just
to show you another form of damage this
is hail damage and you can see the
discoloration in the leaf along with how
the veins are starting to blacken just a
little bit I'm starting to move through
the best there's some of this so
currently there's a couple control
methods that are available to growers
but most of them are preventative as
well as good management practices so for
starters you have just good sanitation
practices with tools and equipment along
with just making sure that the
greenhouse that the regrown is groanin
is sanitized along with this you can
also do crop rotation to help suppress
the pathogen and you can have pathogen
free seeds and transplants which is
always a good way to start and you can
control the weeds that are surrounding
the field especially those that are
possibly close relatives in this sense
to the cabbage and it also has been
shown that some copper sprays have been
helpful in reducing the spread of black
rat as well so for the research I did we
started this on May 5th and we sewed 35
different cabbage cultivar varieties and
we did this face on different harp
harvesting points so we had 10 early
season cultivars 14 mid season and 11
late season cultivars that we planted
and then I'm May 31st after they grew a
little bit we move them up to the cold
frames which essentially it's just a box
with an open lid so those plants can
begin to get a little hearty before they
are transplanted into the field itself
so then on June 12th we started to plant
the cabbage plants by hand there was
roughly about 700 cabbage plants that we
had plant so I fortunately had the help
of the smart lab to help you with
and we did a randomized complete block
design for this planting and the each
cultivar was planted in five plant pots
with four repetitions each so after they
had some time to kind of settle and get
used to the environment and get
established we then went out in the
early morning of June 27th to spray
inoculate with backpack sprayers we did
this in the early morning essentially
because this is when that mutation fluid
is most present as well as this is when
the cabbage plants are transpiring the
most so hopefully it increases our
chance for infection and what we used
was a New York strain of xec that was
isolated from the cabbage in 2010 um so
from there about a week and a half later
we waited to see if infections would
occur and then we started ratings of
percent incidence as well as severity
and we did that once a week for four
weeks and then after we did those
ratings we then waited until the first
harvest so the early harvest of the ten
the first time called barse and then
moved on to the fourteen midseason
cultivars and then the eleven late
season cultivars and when we harvested
we harvested two heads per plot so there
is a total of eight heads per cultivar
and how we rated these was on a visual
basis so this is just to kind of show
you a comparison between a susceptible
and a tolerant cause of our cabbage so
here on your left you have the cultivar
kazuma this is a slightly more
susceptible variety excuse me convert to
black wrap and you can see the
characteristics these shaped lesions on
the older leaves as well as on the
younger leeks that's two and then over
here on the right you have more tolerant
hotbar species so this is a capture and
you can see some of the v-shaped lesions
on older leaves however when you look at
the younger leaves there aren't as many
present if none at all and taking those
pictures onto this graph here this is
just showing the amount of disease over
time depending on
particular cultivars and from what I was
just showing you previously you could
see course uma here all the way on the
left is under the extremely susceptible
and there was you could see the
progression of disease throughout the
growing season however when you compare
that to the capture that I was just
talking about you could see that the the
amount of disease over the growing
period was a lot lower in essence - of
course we moved cultivar so when we did
these visual ratings we started with
looking at the core of the cabbage so we
would harvest basically just cut off the
cabbage head flip it over to look at the
core and what we were looking for this
is kind of the best picture of it is
kind of that blackening the black
lesions of the of the veins going into
the cabbage head and if we saw that
there was a good indication that there
might be black rot inside so after we
did that and all the heads that we
harvested which had black rot we would
then split them in half and look to see
how much infection was actually in the
head of cabbage so you could see on this
picture on her left the black route
moving into the cabbage and then how it
spreads throughout the cabbage head into
the center of the cabbage and this is
essentially what is making the cabbage
unmarketable for growers and these are
just a couple other images to show you
kind of the array if you will of disease
between the cabbage heads so once we
harvested all three season are all three
harvest seasons we then kind of looked
at the total comparison of percent of
affection of the cultivars throughout
those harvest times and you can see that
the early season which was harvested in
mid to late July had the least amount of
infection in the cabbage heads which we
were looking at and any of the cultivars
that don't have a green bar that just
indicates that when it harvested them
there was a zero percent infection in
those heads and as you progress
throughout the season the mid season and
late
in college birds generally had a higher
amount of infection especially in the
late season however I will note that
there are a couple cultivars in the late
season which still had 0% infection or
very minimal percent infection of black
crop
so in summary how would the research
that I did we have done this previous
growing seasons especially the year
before which was completely different
weather conditions however was
interesting to see that even with the
different weather conditions the
cultivar susceptibility basically
remained the same throughout those true
burrowing seasons also as I mentioned
earlier with the comparison of barsoom
a' and capture that some of the
cultivars had infection in the early
stages but once the new newer leafs rose
you didn't see as much infection also
the third point is that the cultivars
showing internal symptoms were generally
associated with the most foliar black
rat and also in regards to the last
slide we looked at looked at the last
graph the mid and late season college
berg showed more internal symptoms of
black rats in the early harvested and
this is essentially probably probably
because they were in the field longer so
they had a greater chance of getting
infected I'm more seriously impacted so
I don't know I'd like to acknowledge dr.
Christine smart for letting me help out
in the lab and run this experiment as
well as Holly Lang who was my supervisor
during this time and also the entire
2017 smart lab the grad students and the
Summer Scholars and also the cabbage
research and development program which
if it wasn't for them we wouldn't be
able to do this research so thank you
and I'm happy to take any questions are
there wild resistant relatives sister
groups of commercial cabbage from which
resistance genes could be harvested or
bred in what's the deal there so I'm not
100% sure so I can't fully answer that
question but I would assume that there
probably are some
resistant cultivars out there which
potentially future research can be done
in that and seeing if somehow we can
inherit a breeding system possibly to
get these calls Barsky more tolerant
questions so I'm curious about the
mechanism in which the inoculation
occurs so since you have the hide their
codes that are secreting water outside
I'm supposing that collects bacteria
does it like suck it back in or
something or does it just sort of
randomly by chance going to the veins
yeah
so in essence that's why we did it in
the early morning because the fluid is
so prevalent so it does increase our
chances for infection and generally the
cute asian fluid is due to the pressure
basically in a root system and the plant
itself can't handle that amount of water
um so it's trying to shoot it out so one
step I would assume once it balances out
with the roots and everything that it
would essentially decrease vegetation
fluid which in essence could suck the
bacteria back and kind of help it get
into the back there's a little bit more
other questions thanks
you
[Applause]
our next speaker is Patrick O'Brien and
he will be talking about a push/pull
agro-ecosystem sustainably manipulating
try trophic interactions so I'm gonna be
talking to you today about biological
control of a invasive pest species in
Africa to start though I'm gonna zoom
way out to a bigger issue of food
security and there's four four points to
food security that matter in this case
availability is is being able to access
your food at any time that you need to
access itself is is related to being
able to have the food in a in a location
that you can reach say we run into this
issue in in urban areas in a in the US
where the the problem becomes the only
available source is there's a liquor
store in the in the area but not any
grocery stores or things like that
additionally we want to we want
nutritious food so I mean the food needs
to be supportive of a healthy lifestyle
for for yourself
and ultimately appropriate that means we
can't just come in and dictate what what
people grow for themselves to lead a
healthy and happy lifestyle so zooming
in on on Kenya itself food security wise
it's 33% of sub-saharan African
countries are food insecure so anything
below the desert are running into a
substantial problem with providing
themselves with healthy and appropriate
food in Kenya itself 80% of the
population either lives off the food
that they grow themselves or they live
of me selling the the agricultural
products that they make and with in
Kenya itself 10 million plus people are
food insecure you can see the more
heavily affected areas here and a little
less so here I'll be working with Boveda
lab down here on this offshoot of Lake
Victoria where it's a little less
affected by food security issues but
this is to note that this is previous to
the introduction of the pests each
species that I'm talking about this
species is adopter of Kruger para or
fall army worm it's native to this
region of the u.s. it was introduced in
2016 they found it in Nigeria and South
tomé and príncipe and since that time it
is now from this line south it is in
every country in in Africa Africa just
happens to have a very conducive climate
to this this insect on breeding and
spreading so here in America we we
control it by a BT crops and by pest
insecticides for the folks that I'm
we're going to be working directly with
it's mostly about subsistence farmers so
on a general basis they can't afford the
insecticides to be used to control this
insect BT is is a non-issue because
Kenya doesn't allow GMO crops so the
difference between a common pests that
Kenya is affected by African army worm
and the fall army worm is that when the
African army worm it targets their grain
crops when it has
said to the point of being satisfied it
moves on to another another agricultural
plot the the fall army worm instead
switches to different host plants and
completely devastates these these two
sis's farmers crops and with that their
livelihoods
so a beta lab is working with ACP the
International Centre for insect
physiology and ecology and we're working
on a push-pull system agro-ecosystem
that is a type of intercropping that
works well on the Triboro frog
interactions that is the effects of the
the host plant and the insect pest and
their natural enemies what we're looking
at is intercropping the corn with a
desmo diem species that is a basis plant
that brings in it adds nitrogen to the
system for the the maize plants
initially desmo diem was used here desmo
diem was used to control Strega invasive
weed parasitic we and they found that it
also releases some volatile chemicals
that that the insect pests are repelled
by so so the desmo diem helps to push
the the insects away from the maize
plants and nature grass releases
volatiles that are an attractant to the
insect pests so in conjunction the the
two species intercropped with corn help
push push the insect pests out to the
Napier grass make your dress also acts
as a [ __ ] butter crop for their animal
livestock so they have that benefit as
well
so what we're specifically looking at is
is how the interaction between the to
help to the the increased diversity
helps bring in parasitoid wasps that
target the insect s species so the
insect though the wasp in question is
shallowness what we saw a year ago was
that even with how how knew how newly
introduced the the pest species is to
the area we found this species of wasps
that typically targets spa doctoral in
general it has switched to the new
target these these introduced species
what it does is it comes in and it finds
the clutches of eggs it lays eggs within
the eggs and it the parasitoid babies
stay within the eggs and into this state
into the larval stage where they they
burst forth similar to the movie alien
to go forward and and terrorize future
spa doctoral so our experiment is going
to be we're going to lay Sentinel
clutches of eggs on within the the
protocol system plots and we're going to
give it a set amount of time we're going
to come back before they become larvae
and collect the eggs to account both the
parasitoid rate comparison size the
parasitism rate and to account how many
have been predated on by other species
so we're going to collect that
information we're going to go to we're
going to be stationed here where is see
fade campuses and will be in this rural
region here working with both farmers
that have accepted the our help here
so we're gonna have roughly ten farms
they're going to be separated by at
least two miles from each other and
we're gonna be controlling for the
push-pull system and unconventional
systems of agriculture for subsistence
farmers on collection day we're gonna
hopefully beat this this instance so we
don't spread more adopter into the
region we're gonna be looking for
basically how much damage has happened
to the plants
recording that's dr. Andre Ressler and
that's Ethan from the kessler lab so
we're gonna be looking at the parasitism
rate we're also going to be running
transects within the the field itself
with bug nets to catch additional
species richness and abundance and we're
also going to do it fall traps to see if
there's any correlation between the
predation rate of the eggs and maybe
some species that we haven't looked at
previously so the outcomes we hope to
have from this is to intensify our
network with with a CPA working with the
farmers themselves and establish a
better network with that this is a very
preliminary work so far and with these
working with the extension workers to
get this information out to the farmers
themselves so that we can start working
on controlling this pest so we're hoping
to find some correlation with the
parasitism rate and the the push-pull
system and hopefully get a damage
reduction for the plants and see a
little more production for the the
farmers itself so I'd like to thank Alex
little fellows their funding me getting
out there havedo lab my mentor copy of
ADA my NPI and the graduate student
who's who's kind of figure headed this
project in Luna Mercer and will be
working
closely with Kessler lab as well dr.
Andre Kessler and from the CEPA campus
dr. Khan and dr. Mann daga thank you for
[Applause]
[Music]
the the armyworm onto the maze park that
over does the does vidya push the
armyworm on to the maze no it it works
to push the the armyworm away from the
insect pest and generally the volatiles
are repellent away from the system
itself in together with the the trap
crop that pulled in a pure grass they
they had just individually they worked
fairly well but together they were
exceptionally well at pulling the the
pest species away from the your crops I
think you said that the caterpillars are
able to move from one plant toast to
another but like how do they do that if
they're little caterpillars well it's
the caterpillars and so stay within the
area the the moths age is highly mobile
so it's been spreading that way and they
just have a very rapid generation time
now that they're in a conducive climate
Thank You Patrick
[Applause]
our next speaker is Katie Mazur and she
will be talking today about crop load
and harvest management for hard cider or
Church thank you Chris yes thank you hi
everyone so today I'm gonna be talking
about my involvement in this while I was
a fruit intern at the Cornell orchard
last year working with so a little bit
of history about hard cider hearts a is
actually very culturally important to
American history well one of the reasons
being is that fruit trees were shown
that you had a long term stake in the
land so as people were moving west and
settling the frontier having those fruit
trees indicated that they were actually
meant there to stay and actually had
stake in the land and one of the more
popular fruit trees was apples so from
that hard cider usually was produced by
many homeowners and farmers it was one
of the more easier things for them to
make especially compared to say grapes
since they're difficult to grow over
things like buy locks rough however if
you jump closer jump forward to the
beginning of the 20th century there was
about three different things that kind
of put the nail in the coffin first out
of production one of them was a large
immigration of northern and central
European immigrants to America who
actually had a preference for beer and
most beer was made from grain it was
very easy to transport that grain the
second one was excuse me prohibition so
prohibition lasted from the 1920s till
1933 and even though there were some
caveats within prohibition for people to
actually make cider at home because it
was illegal to make and sell alcohol
that still put a big damper on it and
the last one was the temperance
religious movement who wide a complete
and utter ban on all alcohol to the
point where they would go and ashlee
burn down orchards as their method of
protest if you will so after that there
was a huge decrease in center production
until about 2011 during that time there
was an astronomical growth in the cider
industry and this was partially due the
craft beer movement and the great
interest in craft alcohol making so from
that there's been a 900 percent increase
in cider production volume alone and in
New York
in 2015-2016 there was over 5 million
gallons of hard cider made so this is
really important in the case of hard
cider is because scuse me cider apples
because Santa rappers make the best hard
cider you can get there it has all the
Tenon's in the phenolic compound need to
make a nice complex cider versus
culinary outlets and in New York this is
especially prevalent because we have
around 100 cider producers which is the
most in the entire country there's a
Saito producer in every single state but
we hold the most out of any of them and
here is actually a little example right
here from Black Diamond farm and cider E
which I believe that's their Hicks
decided that we got to try last year so
there's been a great demand for hard
cider apples but there's been a bit of
an issue nationally meeting that demand
and the reason for that is something
called biannual bearing so this is also
known as alternative or a regular
bearing and there's two different
theories as to why biennial bearing has
occurred so the first one is the
carbohydrate capacity so basically the
tree has so much carbohydrate stored
within it to go through its growth
functions the first things it needs to
do is for growth and survival the second
everything else goes towards flowering
and fruit production
so fruit production fruits are a huge
sink of carbohydrates so when it does
this and I'll show you pictures in the
next slide apples tend to produce
thousands of flowers when they are
blooming so it puts so much of its
carbohydrates into making those fruit
that it needs so that it doesn't
actually produce the flower buds needed
for the next year because they initiate
that the year before so they almost need
that rest period to re-establish its
internal carbohydrate reserves the
second theory is as you can see from the
graph right here involving plant hormone
balance so one of them is the inhibition
of flower bud initiation and that is
done in the seeds right here and they
single gibberellins gibberellins are a
flower bud inhibitor so when a tree is
absolutely loaded with fruit it's also
loaded with a lot of maturing seats
which means that it has a lot of
gibberellin being produced and during
those years there's not that much leaf
production and I say that because leaves
are actually the cycle sorry about that
leaves are actually the initiation site
for something called Florida and Florida
actually initiates flower but initiation
so when you have a heavy crop load here
you don't have that many leaves so
you're getting the trees getting
overloaded with gibberellins therefore
it's not going to initiate new flower
buds for the next year on the other year
the off year it has a lot more
vegetation by comparison so it's going
to be saying okay initiate loss and lots
of flower buds so that's why we get
things we get something in called an on
and off year for trees and that way you
don't get consistent crops for culinary
apples there has been methods of taking
care of this so what they want to
prevent is this right here so you can
see this is a picture I took from the
angry orchard research and development
orchard in Walden New York and the tree
is starting to become overloaded for
flowers and it's not taken care of it
can be overloaded with fruits and there
we go
overloaded with fruit and not really be
able to go to the next year so what
Apple farmers do for culinary apples
which is what you buy at the grocery
store is they'll go through thinning
practices so the quality that those
apple farmers want is different than
what you get in cider apples so they go
through something like this so for
culinary apples the to quality the
qualities are looking for R is related
to fruit size and the overall appearance
of it so here fruit size and yield are
inversely related so the larger the
fruit the lower the yield the more yield
the smaller the fruit so they're trying
to get the most bang for their buck and
trying to find that nice middle ground
economically for them which can be shown
in this growth in this curve right here
so Apple farmers want to go right and
from here they're producing culinary
apples to actually make it profitable
all apple farmers are taught this though
the problem being this doesn't work the
same way for cider apples because you're
looking for something different when it
comes to quality you're not exactly
looking for size you're looking for
other components and the physiology
isn't quite the same so that's where dr.
Greg pecks research comes in is trying
to find out how to get rid of that
biennial bearing and maintain the
qualities needed for cider apples so
this part of the part that I was
involved in was done at the linn open
farm and Medina
York and here is the Oaks family who are
gracious enough to let us conduct the
experiment there and while there we use
eight different hard cider apple
varieties we use chisel Jersey Michelin
been a Roush dab Annette hairy master
Jersey trim lights bitter Garlington
mill and brown snap these are all
European varieties that have been well
known to make good parts so the
experiment this is only one of three but
this is what I was involved with was
crop low density and tree development so
what we are doing there is determining
the overall impact of tree growth on
crop load management because their own
closely correlated so in order to do
that we measured the trunk
cross-sectional area of the tree to get
a proxy for the overall tree size and
this was measured centimetres square so
we had two different controls and three
different treatments so the first
control was we didn't do anything to the
tree we just left it alone to see how it
would work the next one was we
completely stripped it of all fruits to
see how that would affect growth over
the years and then the next three was to
do a low crop load so basically three
apples per centimeter squared in the
tree and then we did a medium of six oh
hi a nine excuse me and from that we did
four single tree bugger it's randomized
per block and then we did ten fruit
samples from each replication to be
measured later on which will explain
what the measurements were and we based
the harvesting time off of maturity
assessments done by Craig kalki who is a
part of the Lake Ontario fruit program
so the measurements that we were going
for were two different things
in culinary apples you want to have a
little bit of starch left over in it
because culinary apples are actually
stored for a long period of time cider
apples are very different
you actually want them to be harvested
Colts the rightness as possible because
they're not usually stored there usually
press immediately to have juice you want
to have different components so that's
why we're doing things like measuring
fruit maturity the starch pattern index
the fruit permanence and the total
soluble cells to measure the sugars and
everything else involved trying to get
it so we can get as much
needed so dr. Greg pecks lab also
measured the cider quality those things
like pH titratable
acid the phenolic contact the ease of
cinebulle nitrogen things that are very
important where you're going through a
fermentation process is it going to be
the right pH for the fermentation for
the yeast to survive are we going to
have the needed phenolic compounds and
the acids to actually create the
complexity that we want is there gonna
be enough nitrogen there for the yeast
to do what it needs to because it needs
the nitrogen in order to form an ferment
properly or are we gonna have to do a
lot of additions in order for it to go
according to plan
for what the cider that we want so based
on of all of this this is just the
beginning of the project so we just
recently within the last month started
actually Reece looking over the results
and everything else so this is gonna be
going on for a longer so the outcomes
and expected benefits of this are to
provide cultivar specific crop load
recommendations to assist growers
because they are different than what a
lot of apple growers are used to and to
provide cultivar specific harvest index
recommendations so they have an idea of
when to harvest for what they have and
to finish it off I would like to
encourage dr. Greg Peck right there and
right there with the other interns that
I worked with last year I would also
like to thank dr. Marvin Pritz who
actually got me on to the fruit orchard
internship because I was actually his
intern we help each other a lot with
different researchers I'd like to thank
Craig kalki who worked with Cornell
Cooperative Extension and the Lake
Ontario program and I'd also like to
thank in New York State apple growers in
the Apple research development program
who helped fund this project and I'll be
willing to take any questions I was
tempted I'm not sure how well that would
have gone support New York apple cider
makers I presentation so I am also
really interested in the biennial
bearing problem and one way that I've
seen on to control
crop load um is to examine I think what
they call the spur extinction rates on
spur extinction rates okay so basically
how often do these sedatives first
disappear and they don't produce flowers
anymore so I was just curious in terms
of cider production are there a lot of
genetic resources of specific genotypes
that have this characteristic and which
we might be able to exploit I'm gonna be
honest I'm not sure I'm not sure how
much genetic research has been done for
hard cider apples there's been a renew
interest and looking into the genetics
and actually start breeding for more
hard cider varieties I know we know that
more for culinary apples but if there's
research out there I'm not sure how much
there is that's probably not based here
but I think there's actually a growing
interest in looking into things like
that and there will be more research on
it other questions okay
[Applause]
all right our next speaker is Nellie
roach and today what there's some
feedback or something today Natalie will
be talking about spreading the word on
plant nutrition and sprouts all right
thank you for that Chris all right hi
guys I'm Natalie and I had an internship
this past winter with Cornell
Cooperative Extension in Seneca County
I'm also a plant science major
concentrating in plants in human health
so a little bit of background on Cornell
Cooperative Extension the smith-lever
act was passed in 1914 by President
Woodrow Wilson and this wasn't created
to create all these property extensions
connected to land right universities in
order to inform individuals on new
agricultural practices home economic and
policy changes so this could involve
different farmers that just want to be
very updated on new agricultural
policies or techniques or it could just
be merely community members that want to
just kind of have more insight onto what
we're learning agriculturally or from
Cornell or other land-grant universities
so this is the idea of taking the
university to the people and kind of
spreading them spreading the word if you
will so some of the benefits of Cornell
Cooperative Extension since 1914 they've
expanded a little [ __ ] now involved
things like life skills nutrition and
health informing people on different
agriculture sustainability environmental
education and even job skills and this
is all with the promise of an unbiased
research so all this research comes from
either Cornell or on other land-grant
universities and all of these can be
done in a community workshop setting so
as seen here this is kind of more of a
community setting this one is actually
in Essex County and this was all growers
and fellow farmers they're learning
different techniques on cherry tomato
and pepper propagation or it can also be
done one on one if you want to just have
a one-on-one meeting and learn about
these things they're also experimenting
now as some like webinar and Skype type
of things they're expanding even their
ability to get this information across
to different people so although most of
these are for adults they also have a
youth development program so it's with a
bunch of kids that can do summer
programs cookouts and just learn to
things about agriculture and other
policies so here's a couple of these
examples here's a 4-h program with
children they're doing cookout here
here we are is a lecture style classroom
setting which would actually the two
workshops I participated in row but in
that style here's a maple syrup workshop
actually which is really cool
um and here is Cornell Cooperative
Extension at the farmers market so
they're kind of telling different people
that are interested in the vegetables on
different ways they grew then and just
giving them a little bit of knowledge on
their food so my work in Cornell
Cooperative Extension in Seneca County
and I worked with Moira tee-ball and
Susan Pearson who were two CCE
nutritional educators and so what coming
into it my two frog my two workshops we
decided to do something based on plant
nutrition and since it's really hard to
get access to vegetables during the
winter months like there's not many
farmers market or not access to local
things so we thought that we'd create
two workshops that people could grow
some plants in their own home so I did a
sprouts workshop where we taught people
how to grow sprouts indoors just in your
windowsill as well as a herb herb
workshop at a let's start in day
teaching people how to you just grow
some herbs the potential benefit or you
can just put it in your winch window so
and then translate it into your garden
in the spring so why do we choose
sprouts specifically so sprouts contain
a really concentrated amount of vitamins
and minerals
it's the sheet of the plant with usually
some two cotyledons
on it and it has a really packed amount
of vitamins and minerals it's also
really low in calories and it's a good
way to add some flavor into dishes so if
you have something like a radish sprout
which is really spicy and you want to
flavor up your salad or stir-fry it for
me you can toss those in there get the
nutritional benefits as well as flavor
also some of them have really good
textures as well I can be like crunchy
they're also organic fresh and they can
be grown all year round if you're
growing them right near home and
something that I found was really cool
dr. Clive McKay who was a Cornell
nutrition professor and during World War
two was the one who actually brought the
idea of sprouts to the public eye so my
sprouts research process I was
researching different primary
articles from Cornell or other outside
universities looking at the different
nutritional benefits and growth time
flavor and then putting this all
together in a giant chart so you can
kind of pick whatever you're wanting to
have and grow those specifically or
whatever you're looking for whether that
was flavor or texture just certain
vitamins for the ones that we focused on
was radish broccoli chickpeas lentils
cabbage and mustard seed sprouts I also
researched a bunch of the USDA
nutritional data that consumers might
find important such as protein amounts
for example a half a cup of chickpeas
sprouts which is not very much it all
has the equivalent protein of four eggs
so that's really great someone for like
a vegan or vegetarian where to know that
and they can coorporate that into their
meals and get enough protein so the
sprouts workshop was presented in the
beginning of January at the Cornell
Cooperative Extension office in Seneca
County and I told people a little bit
about what our sprouts on their
different nutritional medicinal benefits
the nutritional benefits focused a lot
on these vitamins right here the holy I
didn't even a vitamin C an iron and then
I also incorporate some of the medicinal
benefits that some of these sprouts may
have for example like if they had really
high levels of glucosinolates
which can accent anti-cancer compounds
or if they aided in digestion or
something like that you can incorporate
all these medicinal benefits in with
these different sprouts and one of the
questions someone had was why would I
want to eat these sprouts for these
vitamins instead of just taking a
dietary supplement am i intended I was
that these sprouts contain like a bunch
of different of these compounds and
these vitamins and that although they
might may may only provide the I guess
if you could take a bunch of the dietary
supplements they kind of come together
in different things with also
micronutrients they complexly break down
in your body where's one vitamin may
have a role in absorption of another and
they also have different compounds like
antioxidants may be anti-inflammatory
antimicrobial all of those kind of
compounds well that work within your
body
the dietary supplements may not provide
you and then Moira did Bal who is one of
my one of the CCE nutritional educators
presented on how to actually grow these
sprouts so you can go the media like a
colander like up here
there's these trades down here and then
Thiessen you bought at country time
which is kind of up by at room very over
there so it's like a bunch of different
ways you can grow these sprouts right in
your windowsill and then there was a
mason jar in the previous slide that you
can put right in your windowsill and you
just wash it once a day it's super easy
so she presented a little bit and then
all of our workshop attendees it was
about 25 30 people got to leave with a
mason jar a filter a bunch of sprouts
and some sprout seeds to start their own
so some of the health concerns that have
been kind of in the news recently
especially a new case of Jimmy John's
sandwich shop was with presence of E
coli and Salmonella while growing these
sprouts because of sprouts growing
environment is very conducive for these
bacteria since it's warm moist and
everything's very close together so the
FDA suggests that you cook your sprouts
before you eat them to get rid of these
bacteria however people don't usually
eat cooked sprouts usually eat them raw
in a salad or sandwich or something so
if you watch them for two minutes and
kind of a mechanical process of washing
it helps to get rid of some of that
bacteria or if you do want to try to
cook it to kill these but you don't want
to lose all of those vitamins and
minerals that may break down in the
heating process it's suggested to
actually steam them and I guess that
that retains a lot of those compounds
without actually and then you kind of
could see them and kill some of the
bacteria also to refrigerate them after
you harvest your sprouts to decrease the
problems those bacteria and if they
smell musty have dark buds or look slimy
and don't consume them kind of like in
this picture right here so for the
second workshop which was on March 18th
was presented at the Ovid at Firehouse
and it was there the lecture today so we
I researched a bunch of different small
herbs that are local when people are
familiar with the lavender parsley dill
cilantro basil and mint and those kind
of have varying properties summer uses
I'm seasoning and dishes other confusing
as inhalation therapy with lavender for
like stress relief some can be used in
drinks like mint and so I talked a bit
about the nutritional and medicinal
properties of those as well and they
also had kind of similar vitamins and
minerals and also their medicinal
properties
such as lavender with the inhalation
therapy helped with anxiety and helps
you sleep I guess at night so then Susan
Peterson which was also one of the CCE
educators talked a little bit about how
to grow these certain do's and don'ts of
planting these herbs some potential
threats from pests or maybe if you were
to water them too frequently what would
happen so just kind of suggestions for
its people there were fellow gardeners
though so usually this was given I'm a
little bit higher of a scientific level
than the general audience that was
presented for the sprouts workshop we
also talked about some preservation and
recipes so like you can freeze herbs
actually to kind of preserve their
freshness and then just use them
whenever you're cooking then we had a
bunch of different recipes we made with
them all these herbs and we're able to
give them out to people which is nice
and then had some precautions that these
herbs if you're using them for medicinal
purpose they can have certain side
effects or interact with another
medication you're taking so if you were
actually trying to take these herbs like
daily for a certain medical issue then
should consult a physician so this was
the let's garden day in Ovid and this is
the classroom setting so for all these
fellow gardeners is a really great
experience and it was with a bunch of
other people from Cornell as well as I
see that presented on different
gardening techniques or maybe some
pathogens or pests that may be in the
area and so I'd really like to thank the
CCE Seneca County office as well as
Morton ball and Susan Peterson and Patti
Battley who organized a Lexar today so
thank you so much and I will take any
questions
[Applause]
questions what's your favorite sprout
growing method and what's your favorite
sprout I think the trade method works
really really well we grew it on a
couple different rounds at sprouts while
I was working there in the trays it's
found hard to tell in that picture but
the trays have four different sections
you can go for different types of
sprouts in it just kind of nice so we
were like pass it out and whatever
you're kinda in the mood for like I like
the radish sprout the bestest is really
spicy so I thought that was great so you
could just kind of like take out
whatever sprouts you really wanted and
put them into the smoothie stir-fry
whatever you wanted so yeah that was
really cool
I don't want us other questions
[Applause]
okay the penultimate Speaker of the day
penultimate we can learn a new word and
ultimate it's a great word
second-to-last so Meghan Dodge is
speaking next and Meghan it will be
talking about her internship at the
Central Park Conservatory lessons in
urban park horticulture and management
thank you hi so I'm going into landscape
architectures this is going to be a
pretty different talk than the ones that
you've heard so far just to kind of set
the stage an overview of what Central
Park is and its origin it was designed
by Landscape Architect Frederick Law
Olmsted and architect Calvert Vaux in
1858 they want to design competition to
create this massive park in the middle
of Manhattan
it's 843 acres which is about six
percent of Manhattan's total acreage so
it's a pretty big deal and its design
was supposed to be an escape from
urbanism so once you're in the park you
don't even realize you're in a city
anymore
okay so some yearly stats 42 million
people visit Central Park every year
which makes it the fourth most visited
destination in the entire world behind
the Eiffel Tower the Great Wall of China
and the Taj Mahal so it gets a ton of
traffic this is just like a normal day
in the summer home it has a seventy
million dollar budget per year which is
supplemented by the parks department but
it's also mostly funded by private
donations so as far as porta culture
goes I was a horticulture intern this is
the garden that I worked in the
Shakespeare garden it's an essential
green space in New York City it has tons
of different plant species some of them
are very coveted plant species it has
the largest American elm Grove in the
world as a lot of you might know Dutch
elm disease is a problem that's
decimating American elm populations
across the
so it's pretty impressive that this
massive collection of Elms can still
exist in one place throughout the park
there is a lot of variation in design
and habitat there are three different
woodlands a variety of wetlands like
lakes and creeks and ponds there are
formal and informal Gardens the
Shakespeare garden where I worked was an
informal garden and some native plant
meadows that show off New York State
native plants so my duties as a
horticulture intern I shadowed a zone
gardener for the Shakespeare garden and
I helped him with his daily tasks
everything from staking and pruning
watering picking up trash to design a
bed layouts this down here is a bed that
we designed at the beginning of the
summer and it was huge and gorgeous by
the end I wish that opposed to picking
out plants for the following season so
stuff that's in bloom right now I hope
to pick out it's pretty cool probably
the biggest part of my job though was
just interacting with and assisting art
patrons because there's so much traffic
in Central Park every other second
people are tapped me on the back asking
you where's the bathroom where's this
where's that I'm telling about this
plant so that's that's a big part of it
just topic talking with the public I
additionally the internship program
offered opportunities to tour and
volunteer at other New York City parks
in the different five boroughs so I got
to see a lot of different york city
parks and helped out with various
projects okay here is just some photos
of the variation that you can see in
Central Park
up there is the conservatory garden a
little lily pad pond this is the
American elm stand it's a super famous
area of the park called the mall you've
probably seen tons of movie shops in
there the harlem mere and then the rest
of these plants are in the garden that I
work okay so with all that being said
there are some problems with Central
Park and I want to kind of go over those
for being a green space it
very not green it has a lot of
inefficiencies one of them being that it
doesn't have a waste disposal system for
plant matter
there's no composting system in place
they tried to do a composting system in
one part of the park but it wasn't hot
enough to actually degrade the material
so they ended up dispersing tons of
invasives across the park and causing a
lot more problems than health tree and
turf maintenance takes up a ton of the
budget trying to keep trees like the
American elms alive that really are this
inevitably going to die trying to keep
grass green throughout the entire summer
when people are constantly walking on it
so they like recover the lawns multiple
times per season which is very costly
and also removing invasives like mugwort
and hope we takes up a lot of time a lot
of money because there's no protocol for
it once an invasive is removed nothing
is done to prevent it from coming back
so that has to be done like every few
weeks and now there's really no
foreseeable improvement cities because
the part has priorities on aesthetics
versus efficiency so the gardener's
these are some of the people that I
worked with every day this is Russell
Riedel the zone gardener for the zone I
worked in this is Larry Bo's the head
gardener for the Shakespeare garden he's
a mentor and Lisa Kozlowski the head of
the Hallett nature sanctuary they make
the park what it is and they're very
educated and passionate about what they
do they all into school for horticulture
and agriculture and botany and so they
really know what they're doing and they
really care about how the park looks and
how it runs unfortunately in the park
system they are rather underappreciated
and underrepresented a lot of big
decisions that are made they're not
really filled in on they're not asked
about they're treated as scapegoats so
any sort of problem that might happen
like on the ground floor of the park
it's often blamed on them additionally
they're made to do tasks below their
merit they're made to spend at least
like an hour a day or
picking up trash or picking up someone's
dog's poop that they didn't pick up like
all this stuff that really their time
could be used more wisely so these
problems stem from the hierarchy of the
central park system wealthy donors kind
of reign supreme here as I said earlier
they make up the largest portion of the
budget so they kind of get the most say
in what happens in the park there's a
lack of communication between upper
management and the gardener's and this
leads to a lot of flawed landscape
designs and in efficiencies because
gardeners aren't consulted when really
they're the ones who see the park on the
day-to-day basis and know what it needs
additionally upper management values
politics more than the park they care
about connections they care about
knowing New York elite and middle
management is essentially non-existent
as a the beginning of June 50 people
were fired that's 8 percent of the staff
and so now there's like no one in the
middle to kind of like provide a checks
and balance system so some smaller
solutions to these problems these are
just solutions that I'm kind of
proposing not that they're gonna be put
in place but I think that there are some
problems that can be solved
smaller solutions for the near future a
composting site that's pretty doable
just find a site that can get hot enough
have a protocol in place for separating
out invasives from things that can be
used in compost replacing problem plants
such as replacing a certain type of
grass that might Brown easily or not
withstand heavy traffic with a hardy
earth species invasives management
protocol so have some sort of system for
when you remove an invasive prevent it
from coming back white laying down
cardboard or some sort of chemical
deterrent for further future solutions
global warming should really be
addressed in Central Park it's one of
the largest green spaces in the city and
it holds a lot of power there for stuff
that can be done to kind of address
global warming
um use records oh no use reference sites
such as Governors Island Park which was
recently built on Governors Island it's
built with stand 100 years of sea level
rise but Juanes Canal Park which is in
the process of being built in gowanus
brooklyn which has a lot of plantings
that deal with bioremediation like
removal of toxins from the soils and
waters and those are both great ideas
for sort of mitigating problems using
our green space that we already have as
far as the gardener's go some things
that can be done to give them more of
the respect they deserve perhaps we'd be
signs that say respect that our
respective caretakers so people know
that the gardener's are really qualified
people and that they deserve to be
respected
additionally maybe a rebranding could be
done taking cues from National Park
Rangers they have this cool title they
have matching uniforms something like
that just till I give the Central Park
gardeners more as far as the kind of
hierarchy of the Central Park system the
public like New York City public now is
aware that there are problems in the
system because it was widely reported on
when all those people were fired so it's
pretty clear that things need to be
changed gardeners are becoming a lot
more vocal and they're united in their
decision to want to be heard to want to
have more say in what upper management
decides
additionally gardeners supervisors are
in a great position for upward mobility
into middle management because when all
those people were fired they kind of
took on that job anyways the on Central
Park these are some things that should
be addressed long term in the Park
System no two parks are like in New York
City and that's not a good thing the New
York City Parks Department is spread
pretty thin it doesn't have a ton of
funding and the funding that it does
have it kind of displaces towards
wealthier areas for instance High Line
in Chelsea Manhattan gets a ton of
funding it's beautiful it has a whole
bunch of gardeners versus a park like
Marine Park in Brooklyn that has
literally one gardener even though it's
about four times the size of
hyaline and almost no funding and I
think hopefully over time that can be
addressed so all the parts could be
equally beautiful and equally well cared
for as a thank you I'd like to thank
Shanna Blanchard she was the head of the
internship program she hired me and she
was fantastic she showed us all around
New York City
Larry Bose was my mentor and Russell
Rydell who I learned a lot from just
today great people can I take your
questions why is it not good thing that
you say I just think that some of the
parts like really have a lot of
potential but they're just left to sort
of the grade because they don't receive
the same funding that apart in a
wealthier area would get in funding and
in staffing like the High Line has
thousands of gardeners versus other
parts on the other few other questions
[Applause]
our final speaker of the day is
formatted for final speaker our final
last but never ever least would be
Matthew Simon and Hughie talking today I
still love the title
[Music]
summer stress not so amazing so thank
you Chris hello everybody I'm Matt and
I'm going to talk about summer stress
which if you're a corn plant is not so
amazing so specifically I'm gonna be
talking about my experience this past
summer working in dr. yangsun's lab and
soil and crop sciences I was part of a
of the beginnings of a a large-scale
field experiment that is based at
Musgrave farm which is in Aurora New
York and the objective of the experiment
of the experiment that we were setting
up is that we we want to gather
large-scale phenotypic data on corn
crops and field so we did not set up
controlled environment
rather we wanted to just see how corn
crops respond to whatever mother nature
decides to throw at them and so in
looking at that we measured a lot of
different physiological parameters on
the corn crops in the field so to begin
with why are we interested corn why does
one matter well per one corn is the
biggest crop in the USA economy it's
extremely important for export a lot we
export a lot of the corn that we produce
across this country we also use a lot of
deployment we produce in things like
livestock feed and just to give you an
idea of some of the numbers last year
alone corn constituted 68 percent of our
production and grain and oilseed harvest
so you haven't gathered it's a pretty
important crop so before I begin talking
about the materials materials and
methods that we used I said that we
gathered data on a few important
physiological parameters in the corn
that we
and the first one of those is water
potential
so water potential is basically a
measure of the water pressure inside of
a plant it is a measure for whether or
not that plant is feeling water stressed
at the time if you find that the water
potential usually measured in a unit
like bar its pressure if you find that
the water potential is looking pretty
negative that plan is probably feeling
dehydrated if you find that you rather
have a pretty positive value for water
potential then that plants doing pretty
well we also measured gas exchange and
gas exchange in this case specifically
relates to the amount of co2 that is
assimilated by a plant because plants
use co2 filling atmosphere to assimilate
that and fix that into carbohydrates via
photosynthesis and then a byproduct of
photosynthesis is oxygen gas which
plants produce when they during the
light reactions and then the third
parameter that we looked at largely is
chlorophyll fluorescence which and I'm
going to give you a little review of
biochemistry here is I think it's a
pretty interesting topic but it's also a
complicated one so basically when a co
wynia when the plant takes in light
photons of light from the Sun that light
can basically have one of three
different face one of those is photo
chemistry which is just another term for
photosynthesis that uses that light
energy to make sugar that light can also
be given off as heat so it's dissipated
as heat the third way is fluorescence
now chlorophyll which is the pigment
chlorophyll a and B which are the
pigments responsible for capturing light
fluoresce red light as you can see here
and this is a really cool picture under
UV radiation you can see that
chlorophyll fluorescence red light and
so why would we want to measure
fluorescence because if a plant is
fluorescing a lot then that means that
less of that light energy is being
directed towards photochemistry so high
fluorescence likely a lower value for
photo chemistry efficiency so vegan
materials and methods we measured water
potential by using something called a
pressure bomb which is basically a giant
briefcase with a little nozzle here that
you can insert a little leaf cutting
into and then you turn a
another nozzle and you fill a chamber
with gas so you build a pressure and you
get it to the point at which the water
begins to escape the leaf so at the
point at which you see a little water
droplets form on the Leafs cut surface
that is basically giving you the water
pressure of the leaf and typically our
goal is to measure this parameter in the
early morning so around 7 or 8 o'clock
a.m. in the field in terms of measuring
chlorophyll fluorescence and gas
exchange we used a very wonderful fancy
machine called a GFS 3000 and how that
machine basically works is it has a like
a cuvette that you plant on two elite
and first we would dark adapt a leaf
which is what you need to do if you want
to measure chlorophyll fluorescence we
would take a piece of tin foil and wrap
it around to lead so we would
dark-adapted
and then we would take the gfs 3000
which I provided the picture here and we
would clamp it onto the surface of a
leaf and that machine would
simultaneously measure the amount of co2
that was assimilated and basically taken
up by the plant it would also measure
how much o2 oxygen gas is being
introduced into the atmosphere about
little microenvironment Nick you bet and
after shining a bright brief flash of
light on the leaf tissue it would
measure chlorophyll fluorescence to give
us an idea of how efficient that
photosynthesizing so the use of the
pressure bomb and the gfs 3000 were
things we largely intended to use in the
field whereas in the wet lab we did a
lot of chlorophyll quantification by
using a UV vis spectrometer and
basically what we did with this is we
would take leaf tissue from corn plants
we would freeze dry them and grind them
up and then we would extract things like
chlorophyll a and B and carotenoids from
the sleep tissues and we would use a UV
vis spectrometer kindly provided to us
by the Martinez lab on 4/9 to basically
gain an idea of how what the
concentrations of these pigments were
and and finally I wasn't directly
involved in these methods but we also
use a very large metal tower with arms
that we fixed onto it so
we could put data collect data
collectors onto the urns that gathering
data on things like ambient humidity the
amount of sunlight and just gather data
from the environment of the field and we
also use soil moisture probes which are
kindly provided to us by dr. Jeff
laconian so we could gather data on soil
moisture results so this summer was kind
of a washout we had a lot of rain I
don't know what the stats are for Epica
but in Aurora at most great farm they
had the wettest July for I think around
40 something years so it was a very very
very rainy summer so why is that a
problem if you're doing field work
hopefully in a lab something like rain
isn't going to be a problem if you're
indoors but if you're in a field where a
lot of the roads are dirt roads which
turn to mud when it rains very hard
getting to the farm can become a
substantial challenge and so during late
June and the month of July we had a
pretty difficult time getting to the
farm to collect data a few times so as a
result that delayed our collection of
field data until I think it was a late
July and then to early August is when we
really got hit the ground running with
collecting some hard word that we used
became damaged
for instance we used to data collectors
that we stored inside of a styrofoam
cooler which turned out to not be 100%
watertight right there and so because
water doesn't really mix very well with
computer hardware we had to go back to
the drawing board and figure out a new
way to protect that equipment so that
was an ongoing project personally I
thought it was fun a fun thing to work
on but it it was an ongoing challenge
for us and also the metal tower that I
mentioned it's tall and it has a lot of
arms onto it so in the case of inclement
weather and high wind conditions the
middle Tower wasn't super stable so that
was also a source of concern for us I
will go over the fact that I did get
some data the other undergraduate
student that I worked with and loud
we did a lot of practice in extracting
chlorophyll so what we did is we had
some plants that we basically stored in
the sunroom and Bradfield and then we
would snip off the leaves freeze dry
them and just practice the coral
chlorophyll extraction procedure on
those leads and elephant in the room the
16th of June I don't know what I did
there but I made a mistake here such
that I got much higher reads for
chlorophyll and carotenoid
concentrations so sorry ignore that but
you can't see that from May 30th to June
29th the values are relatively
consistent and what we saw is that clerk
will a is present and greater amounts in
chlorophyll B and of course both
chlorophyll a and work will be are
present in higher amounts than
carotenoids which isn't really
surprising because the leaves we
collected for green Gardens are orange
so yeah but I want to mention that the
reason why chlorophyll a is in greater
quantity things work will be is because
while these are both the main types of
chlorophyll that we see in plant leaves
chlorophyll a is known to interact more
directly with capturing light so in this
way chlorophyll a is known as the
primary light capturing pigment so
chlorophyll a is present in the reaction
centers which is like the core of the
reaction center that captures the energy
from photons chlorophyll B are known as
is known as an accessory pigment so they
are inside of the antenna pigments that
surround the reaction Center complexes
and leaves and they basically just play
a hot potato with the energy that comes
valuable takeaway so in spite of the
fact that we were delayed and getting
the field data captured we were still
setting things up and seeing what worked
I personally had a lot of very valuable
takeaways from from this experience
first and foremost I personally learned
that in the case of doing field work
this requires special planning and
foresight that you might not be applying
to working in a wet lab for instance as
I said rain shouldn't be a problem when
you're working in a wet lab rain and
inclement weather are absolutely
something that need to be
considered when you're doing a study as
there other things like pathogens which
did go up due to the fact that we had
very moist conditions this summer so I
learned the value of proper planning in
this case also personally I had a lot of
fun learning to use cutting-edge
equipment as I said I had limited
exposure to using a pressure bomb before
which was a lot of fun and also I had
never used a gfs 3000 before to gather
data on things like gas exchange and
chlorophyll fluorescence so that was
really really cool to learn how to use
that and not just learn how to use those
equipment in the wet lab where things
are pretty ideal it's pretty ideal
environment but to also carry those out
to the field and learn how to use those
in an open environment I also want to
just name briefly the fact that I think
it's really important and enriching to
have a balance between fieldwork and wet
lab work because personally for me that
gave me the chance to see how cellular
and molecular processes that I was
looking at and the wet lab can be
connected to what I see on the whole
plant level in the field so being able
to connect those two observations and
areas of research I think is especially
important and the field of plant science
and also I got to work with some very
knowledgeable and wonderful people in
the lab who know a lot about the fields
and we're very very helpful to Julie the
under 100 graduate student I and
learning at a better performing search
so that being said I would like to
acknowledge dr. eunsung my PI and the
head honcho of the Sun lab dr. christine
chang who was the postdoctoral student
that i worked with dr. Jeff meconium who
provided a lot of very invaluable
insight and help to us and letting us
use his soil moisture probes and helping
us set up and run a lot of our field
equipment dr. carmen aided martinez who
kindly let us use a lot of her equipment
and her lab on floor 9 of Bradfield hall
we used her UV vis spectrometer and also
Julie Levon who was the under
undergraduate student that I worked with
this summer and who I hell up I'm
working with so thank you very much and
I am happy to answer questions
since format well a I think it's
important to point out to everyone that
farming is hard right don't ever forget
that meat and thank a farmer always but
what I did so I guess in terms of the
maize
what are the plans to repeat things this
summer what you know what where are
these experiments going um it is an
ongoing project uh I am not entirely
sure actually Julie is returning this
summer and what I heard I personally am
NOT unfortunately but it's yeah I think
it's it's an ongoing project you gotta
mark and we were this past summer was a
lot about setting up our field
experiments and field data and really
seeing what needed to be streamlined and
given further attention so a lot of it
was seeing what worked and what needed
more attention
this summer I'm probably people have a
little have a better idea of what works
and what doesn't and there will probably
be a drought yes because it's every
other year one year we get wet
conditions in the other year we have so
all right well thank you Matthew
[Applause]
so I would like to thank all of the
students again you guys did a great job
I would love to get a picture of you to
tweet out after so you guys can all just
hang out there and mike has to go there
so I can get a picture everyone to tweet
out and thank Mike my partner in crime
for this capstone seminar series so
we'll see you all next year this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu